I never known how to start these.
I never know how it's just start.
It's weird.
Sometimes you do that breathing thing.
Lately I keep getting excited.
It's been relaxed,
harmonic breathing
in through the nose folks and then I'll do the mouth relaxing.
That's how you supposed to breathe.
It's like that's how you,
that's something you taught me with comedy.
Like lot of times I catch myself doing that and I hear you in the back of my
head.
Just like breathe in and breathe out,
breathing deep breaths and I was like,
wow.
It really does work.
You can get stuck on stage without any air.
Yeah.
We fucked up and didn't plan your breaths and then people were staring and
staring at you going,
why the fuck should we be paying attention?
You stupid.
So you've done that before.
We were like,
you can't even finish a sentence here.
Fairly recently.
Timed it badly.
You know where I pulled it off,
but it's like yikes for close to not.
Anyway,
the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech immune and dude,
we got battle ropes now bitches.
We got kettle bells.
The uh,
hemp force protein powder is in route.
I have a sample right here at Joe Rogan compound.
So,
uh,
we got a lot of good shit coming with on at.com and some stuff that we're
actually gonna talk about on the podcast.
But if you're interested in any of this stuff,
I always encourage anyone who's interested in the topic of nootropics to Google
it.
Go and Google it,
read all the pros and the cons and know this,
if there's anything that we're selling on this show,
anything,
whether it's,
you know,
whether I'm telling you that I support Alienware computers because they support
MMA,
whether it's the,
the fleshlight,
whether it's any,
anything that we sell on the show,
we only sell some shit that's legit.
And I personally am a huge fan of vitamins and nutrients taking care of your
body.
Meanwhile,
just ate a sausage sub,
stupid sausage side.
Did a Wendy's right?
Is so awesome.
There's a Deli in Canoga park that's so fucking old school Italian and they had
a sausage.
Seven I couldn't pass.
But for the most part and eat healthy,
I like,
I will punish myself for that and I want to allow myself anything shit for days
and days.
But that look worth it though.
It was a little bit worth it.
That's worth it.
I believe in cheat days,
man,
I believe,
but I believe you should earn those bitches.
And for the most part you should beat and healthy healthy is fuck you.
Dirty freaks.
So,
um,
that's what,
that's what these nootropics are all about.
It's all about increasing your,
your brain's ability to produce neurotransmitters from wasn't the best way to
describe it.
That would be it.
Yep.
And Aubrey and I both have had a tremendous amount of experience taking these
things long before we ever became involved in,
in selling them and distributing them.
Um,
if there's a bunch of different formulas out there,
a lot of them are good.
I think ours is the best.
And,
uh,
if you want to try it and give it a shot,
the first 30 pills,
we have a 100% money back guarantee so you don't even have to return the
product.
You don't like it,
you get your money back.
We're that confident that it's that good.
We're that confident.
You're going to love it and you're going to get hooked on it and you're going to
be like me.
I didn't take any before the show.
Give me the back quickly.
I panicked.
I panicked that you find out how stupid I am without pot and Alpha brain.
I couldn't work.
I could work,
but I wouldn't be very good.
It's become an addict.
I wouldn't be the same ladies and gentlemen.
I wouldn't be the same way.
And once you get used to those heightened levels of neurotransmitters.
Yeah,
man,
high levels a neurotransmitter's.
Then I'm really addicted to weed when it comes to writing.
I'm telling you,
I sit down and try to write without weed and then I just go,
what the fuck are you doing?
Stupid.
This study's about weed.
What about released a yesterday that that there again,
they went through it and that there was no signs of it being dangerous to your
body or anything at all.
The LD 50 rate is 1500 pounds.
Yeah.
Then know that means that means lethal dose at 50% of the humans.
I mean it would kill the weak bitches,
so you'd have to smoke 1500 pounds to kill the weak vegges.
Guess what?
You're not killing Joey [inaudible].
Joey Diaz laughs that you have 1500 pounds.
He'd give him 1500 pounds of weed and he'll just be running around naked
screaming at people.
You got something that you think you're going to kill me that easy.
That's not going to kill him.
1500 pounds unless you dropped it out of a CIA drug planet landed on his fucking
head.
That's the only way we forced trauma.
The only way to kill the only way.
All Right Ladies Gentlemen,
our Pal Aubrey is back from the fucking jungles of Peru with another Iowasca
adventure.
We're going to,
we're going to get deep experience.
That's still is one of the proudest moments in my life
here in Nick Diaz.
Say That train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Oh.
So that was one of the happiest I've ever been as an adult.
That was like right up there with fucking anything else that's ever made me
happy.
That was so killer.
So your back dude,
I'm back back.
Yeah.
How many times a year are you trying to do these intense experiences?
Well,
you know,
after this last experience I kind of got the message that,
there wasn't too much left for me to explore in this,
but you know,
I kind of see myself as an adventure,
you know,
Cohen back tick,
get knowledge and taking it back and sharing it.
So when you say that in not too much left,
like I always feel like if I do it too much that I'm not absorbing what's
happening.
I always feel like,
uh,
any,
if I have too many experiences in a row,
like two or three in a couple of months,
I feel like I'm just playing.
I'm just a,
it's just,
I'm not just riding a ride.
I'm getting scared.
Right.
You know,
I know it takes a long time for it.
The big ones to make sense to them.
It,
yeah.
I think there's,
I think there's a certain amount of information that needs to kind of accumulate
and you need to get farther off track for your experience to be really what the
people say that a real skeptics,
they'll say,
well,
what information like w w what does anybody ever brought back?
But so you know,
there are there,
there is some anecdotal evidence is some things have been discovered.
One,
LSD and supposedly Francis Crick on his dying deathbed said that he'd LSD
covered the DNA marker.
Yeah,
but you know what,
man?
Fucking on my deathbed,
so many might say,
I turned Christian.
You know,
you're fucking dying man.
He just making shit up.
You know,
he's crazy.
He's dying.
We why his deathbed worth anything,
you know?
I mean death bed.
She'd be like,
don't listen to that dude.
He's fucking freaking out right now.
He's dying.
He,
why did you decide to make up some shit about LSD and the DNA mobs?
Fucking whatever.
I was dying.
I was tripping my balls off like,
but what have you,
like is there like one thing that you could,
like if someone said,
what do you ever bring back?
Is there one thing I can say?
I can give you three things from this last experience that were pretty poignant
life lessons that were told to me just directly flat out that I think will help
me for the rest of my life.
I mean actual concrete things.
This was a very different experience and I don't know if I should just go from
the start or kind of hopping in the middle folks who don't know.
Aubrey had a recent one.
It was about what does it six months ago,
the last one?
Well the Boga was six months ago and then the last trip to Peru was a full year
ago.
So this was the anniversary of that first epic trip and out of the junk and the
first epic trip you,
you went with the same guy that got age called the Dragon Dragon.
Yeah.
And you had some insane visions and you communicated with Flo Tilos of snake.
Like what,
what,
what was it like?
Yeah,
I mean there was a,
the second experience I had,
the first one was just basically coming to terms with my own mortal death.
I mean,
every possible way I could die,
snakes eating out my Oregon sliding down vines that thorns every possible way
that I could confront my death.
I had to go through,
even if he was even,
it was even telling me,
it was like,
your body is riddled with cancer,
you're gonna die as soon as you get back.
And I was like,
oh,
that one's,
that was the one that got me actually the thorns and the snakes eating me and
actually the insects Burling and my skin and exploding all of that stuff.
I was like,
all right,
I'm cool with that.
Like I can get over that.
But then it was like,
your body is riddled with cancer and you're going to die.
And at that point,
what does heck exactly.
But at that point I had to be like,
okay,
you know,
this is the end,
so be it.
And as soon as that happened,
I could feel,
you know,
the medicine just kind of draw me back down into the ground and a deep sense of
peace and I kind of conquering of a fear of suffering that I had.
So you had to just figure out how to let go of the idea that you're going to
die,
which really is the one thing that fucks with almost everybody.
Number one,
pervasive fear.
Yeah.
I've had that conversation yesterday with my four year old.
It's very strange when they started to be aware that you know that people will
cease to exist.
That's a tough one.
So that's why they call it the vine of death actually.
It's one of the reasons is because I watched them,
one of the first things it's gonna do,
it's gonna make you confront your death.
And if you're not ready for that,
you'll fight that.
And you know,
you'll battle with that until end,
but you got to just
kind of get past that first step.
So fortunately the first session I had last time a year ago got me through that.
And then the next one I was just brought to,
to what the shamans called the eight dimension.
They call it out that that's just the paradigm that they use.
But it was just this unbelievably lucid place where I had to get me there.
I,
you know,
I had a flotilla drawing smoke out of me and then I had another one that was
shooting a beam of light under my tongue.
And then I just,
yeah,
I,
it was the weirdest thing.
I have no,
I've since had some people say,
you know,
there's some Yogi practices where you absorb something or another between
underneath your tongue.
But I knew none of that now.
And I don't know if I necessarily subscribe to that even after reading it,
but there is some kind of literature about and underneath the tongue.
But I just did it instinctively and this beam of light just goes piercing
through my tongue.
Yeah.
I wonder it's because p is sub,
uh,
um,
sublingual,
drugs.
Yeah.
It's a very,
it's a very strong absorption side.
Yeah.
Like it's like the easiest way to absorb directly into your bloodstream.
So it was kind of an odd,
odd thing for me to do without thinking about it.
But after that happened,
I just burst into this other dimension.
And from that dimension I could see people that I wanted to see.
I could scan my body,
I could look towards the future,
towards business,
towards anything,
and everything was just perfectly lucid in this universe that didn't change no
matter which direction I looked at.
And it was incredibly profound life changing experience in the last session,
did it seem,
when you were looking at like the world and all the different aspects of you,
have you have your world,
did it seem like something you're creating in your mind?
No,
it really didn't at this time.
You know,
and,
and I've had,
I've had some silly silicide and experiences and some other different
experiences that seem very much like an exploration on a ride through my own
subconscious,
you know,
like going through the dream state processing,
bad emotions,
bad feelings.
Um,
but something particular about the DMT experience and the Boga experience
transcends that kind of feeling like you're on a ride through dreamland,
you know,
that really is your own,
mind you,
it felt completely different because I was so lucid,
I was so able to just navigate through a different space where only the shaman
was sharing that space.
The rest of the people around me were just these spindles of light that I could
kind of see through and I had full options to do whatever I want.
I even ran back to my cabin and shot a little video where I look really kind of
weird and a little bit freaked out.
But I was like,
I had to capture that moment because I was worried that I was going to forget
it.
So you've got a video of you talking about what you'd just turn experiencing
currently while you were already experiencing it currently.
So I turned the camera on myself and I was like,
you know,
this is me.
I made dimension of space of infinite possibilities and I'll show you there or
something like that.
But,
but I had such freedom to just do whatever I wanted in that it seems almost
impossible to me that that was generated by my own mind.
So what do you think it is then?
I mean,
it is generated by your,
your own mind interacting with a drug.
So,
but does that drug act as a doorway?
The new experiences?
I think it does.
I think what DMT does is it opens up the realms of Pos,
opens up the other dimensional realms where there's knowledge and information
that wants to come and access your brand.
And you know,
you want to receive information from those other,
other dimensions.
And how it comes to you is generally there's a,
there's a translation gap.
You know,
there's no Rosetta stone there.
So it comes through generally is pictures.
And these pictures can often be very confusing,
but it's really trying to translate information that it,
that your brain wants to get access to.
And the only way it knows how to do that is to show you pictures.
So you explore these pictures and find answers,
um,
from,
you know what I believe is another,
either the collective unconsciousness of all people or another dimension that's
even higher.
That's beyond people that transcends people.
That's a wisdom older than people.
And I think that's kind of where you're accessing this information.
I think also there's also some component of your own of your own mind and
consciousness.
But I think DMT in particular is a,
is a pretty unique molecule that really allows access from,
you know,
some other spaces that are non self-generated.
It certainly,
it certainly seems like that when you're doing it,
but nobody knows what the fuck that really is.
What are you doing over there Brian?
Looking at cat pictures.
Okay,
let's do that one.
The podcast.
It's very distracting.
I'm looking at you on the screen.
If you want to look up cat pictures stretch us out so you don't have to be
looking like a fucking weirdo catch stalker corner.
Um,
um,
when,
when you,
when you take it and you have that feeling though,
do you think it's possible that feeling is just a drug interacting with your
mind?
Cause that's like what the skeptic would say.
Right?
Sure.
It's certainly possible.
I mean you can't,
you how do you,
how can you rule that out?
And actually that's one of the things that,
you know,
and I'll get into that a little bit more in the second experience cause the
second experience,
this one I just got back from,
I had actual encounters with allies like different beings that were talking to
me and that's the first time that's ever happened.
Like the last time they were giving you good advice.
Yeah.
They were giving me good advice.
Do you think that that's possible,
but that's like part of your personality.
That's definitely possible.
Impossible.
You know what I mean?
Like there's like some area of your personality that subconsciously needed to
get expressed.
And so what it's done is it's created a character.
Sure.
It's going to guide you.
I mean,
I don't know.
Look,
that's the,
that that's absolutely possible.
And I'm not playing devil's advocate.
I just really don't know.
I'm,
I certainly,
it certainly has felt like when I've had DMT experiences that it was wasn't in
the same places I am now.
I felt like I was in a new world and I definitely also was kinda tweaked by the
fact that I was myself.
I wasn't drunk,
I wasn't and I wasn't,
I wasn't myself tripping balls.
I was myself seeing something that was impossible.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing how that experience hits you where it doesn't change your own
personal fee,
the way you feel physically,
the way your mind works.
It doesn't change that.
It just explodes.
It seems like a doorway,
but I don't know what the fuck is really going on.
That's,
it's interesting.
Yeah.
So I'll tell the story of how I encountered these beings and then we'll,
we'll try and figure it out.
Cause I had a lively debate.
I was actually down there with my friend Bodie and we had a lively debate.
He was on the camp that it was just,
you know,
parts of my own mind for me,
I wasn't quite sure.
It seemed like there's something there or to be confident in either or as silly.
Yeah,
exactly.
How consciousness is created by chemicals.
Okay.
You need all these different chemicals in order for a human being to have a mine
that's functioning and this consciousness of the human mind has manifested a
physical reality that is almost impossible to imagine me think of airplanes and
the Internet and television and fucking giant buildings and shit.
These are all come from chemicals.
Chemicals have produced chain reactions.
They've produced,
they've set into motion a chain of events that have fucking eaten.
Every fish out of the ocean polluted everything,
you know,
figured out how to drop bombs that incinerate a half a million people at a time.
I mean,
this is all come from chemicals.
So why would we be tripped out that the idea that you introduce a different
chemical and you literally change dimensions.
Yeah,
I mean the chemicals in this dimension of change the shit out of this place,
you know,
and that has done it in the form and the manifestation of human consciousness.
Why wouldn't we think that another one that you add to human consciousness might
elevate you to some different place.
And that's what I think the real shame about all the,
the drug laws that disallow these different explorations.
Because you know,
at this point it's just such as still such a small amount of people that are
accessing this that are able to research it.
I mean,
the Lebron James of psychedelic tripping has not been discovered yet.
You know,
like,
he's like the person who can go go out there and pick up information that's
completely different and bring it back and solve some of these mysteries.
It's just,
you know,
you got to have a basketball court on every bra,
every block to produce the bond James and you gotta have psychedelics legal,
you know,
to get enough of people to get the super,
the super explorer out there and have access to it.
Yeah.
And I think also collectively we learn from each other's experiences.
I know that,
you know,
when I have had friends that have tripped and came back and had a different
perspective on themselves,
you know,
just absorbing their story and absorbing their experience.
And then you have your experience compounded with the information that they kind
of gave you about their experience.
And it all builds up together when you're just by yourself alone and a fucking
cabin in Vermont and your trip and your fucking balls off with nobody to talk
to,
you know,
it's like,
did you meet,
what was that movie,
uh,
into the wild?
Is that what it was?
When the kid goes up to Alaska and,
uh,
one of his,
one of his big things as he realizes,
he,
he can't have fun unless he is with other people.
Like you're not,
you,
you can't enjoy your life unless you were the other people.
Like the idea of going on here,
social creature,
you can't just be in Alaska and go this so beautiful going to be so happy.
You know,
you where is,
where is everybody?
It doesn't matter how many flashlights you have,
it's still not going to be fun.
Yeah,
there's a show that I've been watching lately.
It's called the mountain men and this is false.
Three different dudes,
one in Alaska,
one in Montana and one in North Carolina.
And the guy in Alaska,
man,
this motherfucker is a trip.
This guy gets in a little float plane and he takes off and he fell.
He flies three hours into the woods where there's no one and he gets there and
goes to his cabin and when he goes to his cabin and then he asked to take piece
by piece his snowmobile,
I said take the parts out and put them back together.
By the way,
it's 30 below zero as to put the parts back in the daytime as to put the parts
on a snow machine together.
If there are then a,
he kind of got my time and you hear that and then he drives 24 miles on a
snowmobile,
24 miles to check is a string of traps and that's what he does every day.
He did it every day for months and he made $4,000 $4,000 for doing like the
hardest shit you've ever seen in your life.
This guy is,
first of all,
he's,
he's trails will disappear because the snow will hit so fast.
By the time we tried to turn around and drive the trail back,
you can't see what the fuck is going on.
So he hits logs and breaks his skis and he's like,
if you get hurt out here,
you're fucked.
Like you know,
really your f three hours by plane into Alaska,
there's no one there,
no one.
And this fucking guy is driving around killing animals with these springy metal
contraptions.
It's snap their heads in and they'd takes their skins and sells them.
It's a hard man.
Meanwhile the dude's seems happy as fuck.
That's the crazy thing about it.
The guy seems so happy.
He seems like he's having a great time.
And,
you know,
we were talking earlier about people who are on antidepressants,
like what number of people are on antidepressants and how weird it is when
you're around someone is loopy on antidepressants and you're like,
I wonder how much of our brain is just fucking designed to be a hunter and
gatherer.
And despite the fact that we've evolved way,
way past that societaly the physical bodies slowish shit to catch up to
technology.
Yeah,
for sure.
I read a book by Bertrand Russell called Conquest that happiness and here's a
preeminent kinda 19th or 20th century philosopher and a in that book he
describes like a gardener that they had and hit and Ms. Gardner,
he said was one of the examples of the happiest people he's ever seen.
And he lived in a very affluent kind of British society.
Um,
and he said one of the reasons his keys to happiness was every day he went out
and he,
his job was to hunt rabbits cause the rabbits would tear up the gardens.
So that was his daily challenge that he got to do.
And he was had like every morning he woke up and he was like,
I was goddamn rabbits,
I'm going to fucking get them,
you know?
And that was that for him was all he needed to everyday have that challenge and
have the ability to meet it and feel like he was making a difference.
That's what made him happy.
So similar to your mountain man,
you know,
he goes out and he goes after
those animals and he has that challenge against nature,
challenge the catch the animals and then come back and get it.
And I think that makes them happy.
But these people who have these jobs that feel like they are completely
meaningless.
Like what are you doing?
What are you creating?
It's monotonous.
It's the same day.
It's not a challenge anymore.
You're just clocking in.
Yeah.
I think that makes it even more,
more difficult to maintain happiness.
Well,
everybody can't have the perfect life,
unfortunately for society to work like this,
the only way to have a gigantic society,
the way we have here is there's a lot of people have to do shit that sucks.
Yeah.
They,
they have to,
and you get talked into thinking that,
you know,
you're going to get out of college all I needed to just get a good job and
you're going to be fine.
No,
no,
you're not going to be fine.
You're not going to be fine for eight hours.
You're going to be in pain every day.
It's not a lot of pain,
but it's a mild pain.
It's the kind of pain that makes you shoot up a post office and do absorb it for
30 years.
That's what it is.
It's just mild pain.
Especially when you make the releases illegal.
You know?
I really think if you're going to be in that kind of situation,
there's a lot of people that are,
well if you do,
you better get out and fucking camp on the weekends and go find nature again.
Cause that's part of what I think is another key.
It probably why your mountain madness so happy cause he's connecting with the
natural world,
which I think is another big key.
So you better go out and fucking camp on the weekends and every six to 12
months,
you know,
I believe that a psychedelic reset can be extremely valuable,
can kind of purge all of these kind of negative emotions that you felt and then
you can kind of go do your job and checkout and live for other things.
If your girlfriend for your workout that you have at the end of that fucking job
or bust your ass Pressfield's turning pro or worry about it,
get the fuck out.
That's my ocean.
Towns are so happy every time you go to the ocean town.
Like it's always happy and positive and people are ha,
you know,
like,
because they're humbled by nature every day.
You're humbled by nature.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
I did.
Mountain towns are like that too.
Yeah.
They're,
they're nice people because they're humble.
They're humbled by nature.
It's a different kind of humbling the mountain towns cause it's a cold weather
sort of button down the hatches.
Do you guys need help changing your flat?
You know,
it's like that kind of happy.
But,
uh,
the,
the ocean towns are always like laid back cause like you just look out of that
ocean and go shut up bitch.
I can't,
nothing be important.
Look at this,
this crazy puddle of water we're in front of.
Yeah.
I tell you man in San Diego I was there for comic cons and you were also,
it's so beautiful.
Like I did that one bridge,
that humongous bridge that kind of goes around where it's just super high up.
It's blue water.
San Diego Shits on La,
get those negative ions off the water.
It's,
we had the weed.
I you do feel that that marijuana laws or at least it's tolerance is completely
different than what it is in Los Angeles.
They have,
they have a really hard time putting up dispensary's there.
They keep getting shut down and then like,
like the people that worked the doors are all ex military guys so they enforce
it more.
You know,
it's like you can see how it just spreads.
Like we could barely find a place to smoke
a joint in San Diego near a comedy club.
You know,
at first we were like trying to go on the sidewalks and we got kicked off
torches and yeah,
it's a lot trickier than it isn't La la so ridiculous right now.
It's like the folks who live in other parts of the world,
you don't realize how suppressed you are.
You come to La and I mean,
and they keep talking about clothes and places down.
They did target after the big places.
That's what they do.
They target after places like Oaksterdam.
There's another place.
And,
and the good thing about these big places as those guys generate enough money to
fight it in court.
And so hopefully some,
some good will come out of it.
But you have no idea how many there are.
You have no idea.
There's way more than there are Starbucks and Mcdonald's combined.
And when you hear the shit with the raids and stuff,
it's,
if you look at the shit like the why they got raided cause they were operating
without a license,
you know,
they weren't
many places that are just breaking the laws.
No,
no,
no.
What's that last one Tommy Chong said is right there.
The one in Long Beach where they,
the cops stepped on the kids and those,
fuck yeah,
they didn't have a license and the guys,
but the big ones,
they're getting,
the DEA is going after them because they have a lot of cash.
That's one thing.
They're stealing their money.
They're going after when they take their pot and their money and you know,
good luck getting neither one of them back and a year later your pots not worth
anything anyway.
Stupid.
You know,
at the time you go through the legal bullshit.
Yeah.
Here's your pot.
By the way.
Most of it's probably already smoked.
He ate probably smoke this shit out of your fucking weed.
They resold it,
required it.
Well,
Obama said that he was only going to go after people that weren't violating
that.
We're violating both state and federal law.
That's what they said at first.
But they have a sense not,
they've not lived up to that cause a,
that Oaksterdam place wasn't violating state law.
They're just,
you know,
it's a,
it's a fucking,
they got to keep busy and it's an easy way to rescue people and not get shot.
You know,
go try and raid the meth lab with such confidence.
go try it.
Yeah.
You step into a fucking meth lab,
dude,
you might get shanked there might be a dude hanging by his heels from the
ceiling ready to drop on a cop cause he's like,
that's what he does.
Cause it's a method out all day and he's got a knife in his teeth.
Yeah.
You don't want to do that.
Kick in in a math lab is dangerous.
They'll throw a grenade at you and blow it up right in front of them.
They're fucking meltdown.
They don't know what they're doing.
The cops,
when they go and break out a,
a medical marijuana store,
it's like you might as well be arresting babies,
you know?
And then when he's fighting back,
you know,
meanwhile comps are smashed and the cameras and shit,
the whole thing's disgusting.
If this was a cvs pharmacy,
they get right down the street.
You would never think about doing that.
Meanwhile,
those mother fuckers are dispensing Oxycontin's on the regular people are coming
in every day that are stone cold opiate junkies and cvs is just keeping them
alive,
keeping them alive and giving them bottles of pills.
And some of them they smashed snort
and some of them may smoke and some of them they just take.
And meanwhile the medical marijuana place get on the ground.
Yeah.
Plants.
Do you guys have flowers?
I think the biggest problem is the reason why it's not already legal is you
can't patent pot.
It's just too easy to grow.
Too many show could do it so they can't control it and they can't monetize it.
The corporations can't do it.
There's the APP for sure.
For sure.
I mean,
there's no other,
you have to follow the money and all of these cases and there's just no other
good reason.
Except I guess in some cases like at Boga and Iowasca.
I mean,
nobody's going to do that shit for fun.
it sucks.
You're puking,
you're shitting,
you're like,
it's,
um,
it's a tough tomato.
Not everyone's growing tomatoes.
And it's true.
Even easy.
Yeah.
Even easy shit like tomatoes and I said it's fast.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Celery,
grow some bamboo.
Grow your own bamboo.
Bamboo grows like fucking an inch a day.
It's constantly growing.
It grows fast as shit.
Nobody's growing it.
Just make it cheaper.
You know?
It'd be like being able to buy a pound for five bucks.
Well,
the idea that you could be growing like lettuce and I can come along and say,
you can't grow lettuce.
If there was only two of us,
that would be so ridiculous.
You're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Get get away from me.
I'm growing some lettuce.
There's only two of us.
It would be,
but if there's 300 million of us,
you can come up to me and say you can't grow marijuana.
I'd be like,
what are you talking about?
Why are you telling me what to do ever?
Well,
you only reason why it's seems like you should be allowed to tell somebody who
would do is when there's,
you represent some giant group of people,
like there's a bunch.
And so there's bunch has decided they don't like you doing this and they haven't
even decided to by the way,
you know,
it's like what it is is a bunch of a giant group of people who are making money
from other things and are worried that you're going to take away some of their
profits with this plant that you want to grow.
So they go and they pay off the cops and they,
they literally do,
they give them money and then they give politicians money.
They give it to them,
they give them millions of dollars and they say,
we want to make sure that this,
this position is supported.
And so they go out and they bust pot shops.
I mean it's really that us and not,
and even as crazy
male species of hemp,
you know,
we can't grow that.
I can't even say I have to source our hat for this new protein that we got from,
from Canada.
And it comes in just the male species and it's so easy to grow sustainable for
the soil.
You don't need pesticides.
The protein it produces is one of the most nutritious protein for you at all the
fibers you can use for clothes.
I mean,
and it's illegal.
The fucking car,
it's inquiry and it doesn't even fucking,
it's not even psychoactive at all.
No.
It's illegal to grow a plant that doesn't even get you high because it's related
to a planting.
That's food.
It's going to be even,
I mean,
you know God for,
God forbid there's some kind of hunger issue that comes from any kind of
collapse or something like that,
but then you got a plant that's about the easiest motherfucker to grow that can
feed people and clothe people
and you're like,
no,
no.
You did not want that because why?
Well,
because it's sister makes people,
makes people happy while they're selling oxycontin's by the truck load.
Yeah.
They got truck mom passing each other on the highway filled with oxies.
Wow.
Everywhere you go oxies actually,
what do you got there?
Nothing just from pharmaceuticals and bringing a cvs.
You're up.
Go on your way.
Yeah,
I always thought it was that.
A roach in your fucking ashtray,
boy,
you know they'll pull you out and beat you if you have a roach in your ashtray.
But they'll,
they'll look at your papers and go,
what do you got?
Enough oxygen cotton in there to kill a fucking country.
I always thought it would be a good,
a good skit by some enterprising pioneer to take a cop out to a cow pasture and
find like a magic mushroom that's growing in the cow pasture and walk with the
cop and it just find the exact point where it becomes illegal to touch something
that's growing out of the ground.
You know,
just bring them,
come up to it and come close to it and it's this.
Okay.
And then just touch it with if you cluck it.
Am I,
do I own this now?
Yeah,
I PR and now I'm a prisoner.
Can you pet it?
I mean when,
at what point does he smack you in the face and handcuff you?
If you'd pick it up by the Turd.
I'm not even touching it.
I've got a shovel.
Right.
Shoveling the Turd.
I mean,
just to find,
I mean it gets so absurd at that point,
you know,
when this natural substance becomes illegal,
they were legal in England for into really,
really recently.
But it's probably because Americans went there and took too many mushrooms to
freak the fuck out and ran on the streets.
Like,
all right,
we got to stop this shit.
Maybe or they just had too many good ideas.
Yeah.
Hope.
Well hopefully that was the reason.
But I guess,
you know,
there is some,
there's the two promising fields.
There's some pretty good research coming at Johns Hopkins had that one on
suicide and that was good.
Maps is doing some good work.
Some other people are doing good work,
but then the,
uh,
the Church of Santa Di may want a big case,
um,
for,
uh,
I Wasa as a medical,
I mean as a religious sacrament.
So that's kind of another angle that's kind of allowing some of these medicines,
um,
to get in through a loophole cause you're allowed.
And I know the native American church already got Payoti approved.
And then this Church of Santa diamond or either them or the EDV,
I dunno,
they're both thinking about that.
EDV Yeah,
both are trying.
I think one succeeded ones in the works,
but it's vegetal.
How does the EDV,
what does he bowser breakdown something that vegetal or something like that?
Yeah.
Well for folks who don't know what these are is they're Christian groups that
are from Brazil and they combine,
uh,
Christianity with Iowasca.
It's,
it's a very strange sort of offshoot of religion.
They take really high level psychedelic drugs and they sing songs about Jesus.
I have a friend who went and said it is crazy.
Yeah.
He said that was a,
there was a showman down in the area that we were at.
Who does that?
Who combines,
who blends,
you know,
Christianity with the jungle beliefs
of Iowasca.
So the beings that he's talking to sometimes,
you know,
it's um,
spirit of mother Iowasca or whatever and other times it's straight sweet baby
Jesus that he's,
that he's trying to talk to and that actually throws some people off.
I definitely prefer my,
my job and to be straight straight jungle beliefs.
That really begs the question then,
what's going on?
What's going on?
Is,
is Jesus real or is everything you can imagine real and is your imagination
concocting all this shit.
And is the imagination sort of being underestimated or downplayed or um,
maybe mischaracterized.
You know,
we look at the imagination as something that creates some bullshit.
Something that's not real.
Something that the cranes,
things that are imaginary,
you're making it up.
They don't exist.
But maybe it's much more complicated than that.
Maybe their imagination is a reality.
Creating frequency.
Maybe it's a,
you know,
maybe it's something that actually does mean from out of the,
out of the imagination comes everything.
Right?
It's true.
There's fucking computer didn't exist until somebody imagined it and then made
it.
So it's that.
It also could be that these,
these are really archetypal forces.
So like if you're talking about,
you know,
St George or Saint Michael or Jesus,
you're just basically giving a name to a spiritual force that has certain
characteristics,
but you're also giving them a name and giving them a face.
Yeah,
yeah.
But it's all part of the thing there.
I think it might be all part of the translation mechanism.
You know,
it's communicating to you in a way that makes the most sense to you.
but so let me,
let me get into the full store cause I've had some encounters with some
entities.
Brian,
do you have the,
you have the music might be kind of cool to cue this up so you can get a taste
of what I was hearing as I was going through this.
Uh,
and this is called,
what are they called?
He could also,
and these are passed down grandfather to grandson and their songs that they sing
while the Io Oscar ceremonies going on and they take the Iowasca with you.
So they learn these songs while on our Alaska and they sing the songs while on I
lost SCA and also smoking the nicotine.
I rooster Tika cigarettes,
which is the different type of tobacco,
you know,
wine is tobacco.
Um,
play a part in it.
Like the blow tobacco on your face.
Yeah.
That's kind of a cleansing ritual,
but tobacco apart.
But I think it also has some effect on opening up the reactors in your brain.
So it kind of activates the IOWASCA experience.
I think the,
I don't know,
I could do a little bit more research on the science behind it,
but I think the nicotine has some similar effect to the DMT reactors.
Well,
it's amazing how many people are missing misinformed about nicotine.
Nicotine actually is good for you.
Yeah.
Like nicotine is healthy for people have bad heart.
It's like,
it's like you could use it as a medication in some circumstances.
It's just smoking it with like 590 other chemicals.
It's not so fucking fantastic smoking a period
when you're getting a bundle out of the jungle.
I think it's a little different.
Yeah.
And cigars are different too.
So anyway,
this guy's singing this thing.
Yeah,
he's tripping.
Balls are,
so this is,
this is this the first time I had kind of a real physical purge,
not too much to talk about.
I was nauseous the whole time.
I was puking and shitting and it was more about my body getting prepared for the
second session.
So the second session I doubled up on the cups and it's about an hour and a half
in and listening does,
you're basically hearing what I'm hearing at this point in time.
The shamans kind of rattling his leaves and singing his songs and uh,
and then the experience starts to get rich like it did,
you know,
at the time before and what appears to me is like a nexus of energy right in
front of me.
And unlike last time where things were coming at me,
snakes and eels were just charging at me from all directions.
This time it was subtler.
I felt like I was looking into like a black hole or wormhole.
What does that sound?
The whistling?
No,
the,
the background,
that's the,
uh,
I dunno,
the cricket tie.
That's the ink techs and the Johns,
the insects and the jungle.
We're outside in the jungle.
Yeah.
I mean this is the real jungle dude.
Just that alone.
Yeah.
No,
it's true.
It'll get me,
somebody got to rattle and I'm like,
what is that?
Is that a rattle and no,
that's insane.
Yeah.
So it'll,
Ohio sounds like it at night.
I don't think Ohio,
so I was quite like the joggers.
No,
those insects.
I'm sure there are some insects in Ohio.
There's some insects out here at night too,
but not so much here.
I'm on an MP three player,
like Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
totally.
Really?
Yeah,
100%.
Maybe the,
I dunno if it'll catch something scary or about the jungle,
jaguars and monkeys and all snakes or anything like that.
No,
we did see,
uh,
we did see a taper though as we're going through,
which is pretty cool.
Oh yeah.
Well it was little.
I need your guys.
But anyway,
so I,
it appears to me as like a nexus and it's nothing much has happened to phone.
Is there an x,
a little phone?
No,
but it's like a vortex,
let's say like a vortex.
And it's kind of swirled with some different colors,
purple,
and it's just kind of waiting there for me.
So I was like,
well,
I guess maybe I should ask something to come through it because nothing really
was happening.
So I'm looking at,
I was like,
hi,
I'd like to be,
you know,
if anything's out there on the other side,
please come to me.
And I say that to myself and my head and then bursting through it comes these
huge dragon,
like this giant 10 is the dragon head was just 10 feet right in front of me.
And it was a silver dragon in the kind of medieval stylings.
And it had fluorescent green and blue highlights and smoke was coming out of his
nose and he was like,
clearly a fire breathing dragon.
And he goes,
he comes right up to me and he goes,
uh,
so you want to change the world?
And I go,
yes.
And he goes,
why?
And he's like flaming,
coming out of his mouth.
And I was like,
cause that's what I'm here for.
And he goes,
law,
ah,
and laughs and for whatever reason I decided to take them like neverending story
and I just hopped on his back.
Yeah.
So I hopped on,
I hopped on his back and uh,
and he starts cruising,
you know,
and we're kind of cruising through and he goes,
so why do you want to change the world?
This seems like a kid's movie.
I know you guys.
Right?
It was fully never ending story.
And I go,
I go,
uh,
to help people.
And then I thought that was a pretty good answer.
And he goes,
are you sure?
And then right there he like shows me a cross section of my life and all my
actions.
And what he showed me was that even though ostensibly I do a lot of things to
help people is always,
always a serious component of propping myself up,
my own ego,
my own persona and my own kind of establishing my own self in the world.
For,
you know,
egoistic and pride reasons.
And he just showed me this like lucidly clear,
you know,
that there was a mixture of,
of my actions,
you know,
and he wanted to mess with all of us.
Yeah.
And he wanted to have me be aware that of where that boundary line lie and not
to trick myself for confused myself and thinking that,
you know,
what I was doing wasn't also for my own benefit.
That was like,
all right,
dragon egg,
like one point for you.
And then he's,
so we're,
we're cruising so there were keep crews in and he starts to really get heated in
the mouth.
Like flame was trickling out and he goes,
it was a,
what do you want to destroy?
And he likes swoops down and I was,
I was sure he was ready,
just fuck some shit up.
So I was like,
ignorance.
And I thought he was just going to lay the ground with fire,
you know,
and instead he goes,
should not be what you want to heal.
And I was like,
Yup,
I guess you're right dragon.
So he was really like challenging me in these answers that I gave him,
which was a pretty interesting kind of experience,
you know,
for,
for this other entity to be clearly,
you know,
showing me different sides and teaching me things that I clearly wasn't quite
aware of.
Maybe you were maybe somewhere in the back of your head we're aware of,
you know,
your shortcomings are not even,
not even shortcomings,
just slight bullshitting.
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
we wanted to just carve away all that nonsense and then,
and then show me the rest.
So the Dragon,
I was still on his back and he drops me off in the woods.
Right.
So he drops me off in the woods and I,
and I'm walking through the woods.
Okay,
so you laid him in.
How did you get to the woods though?
I'm on the Dragon's back.
Full neverending story.
Imagine the nobody even really in the woods,
you really in the women,
the jungle,
but whatever that is,
you really get there though.
I mean,
you really didn't fly around in a fucking dragon,
did you?
Well,
in my mind I did.
You just kind of not a dragon and then all of a sudden he drops me off and I hop
off.
I don't know the details of how I got off the dragon into the woods or under
what was really going on while you,
what would I have seen?
Are you on a dragon now?
Drag it,
drag it.
Like what would a a wonder what I would see if I saw you doing that?
Would you just be walking and I'll be good.
What are you doing?
Sitting,
drag you down with me so much about myself.
Like a fucking dragon.
Are you talking about man?
Yeah,
exactly.
So anyway,
so I dismount from the dragon somehow and I'm in the woods and I see a bear and
the bear has a big giant crowds,
like a terrible idea to be tripping your balls off in the jungle.
Yeah.
Wandering through the woods by yourself.
And I'm assuming it's nighttime,
it's nighttime.
Well,
I'm,
I'm laid out.
This is all happening and this is all happening in my mind.
Okay,
so you're not even move.
I'm not even moving.
Okay.
No,
I'm fully,
you weren't actually in the woods.
No,
no,
no.
I'm on my back and the jungle and the physical world.
And then in the mind's eye,
yeah,
my mind's eye walking around for real close care.
Yeah,
that's a little scary.
So I get dropped in like a forest and it was like a woodsy forest,
like a Colorado type for us different than the jungle and a,
I see a bear and the bear has a gold crown on his head and a bunch of gold
chains all over it.
Mr t bear.
Exactly.
And the bear is kind of struggling and I see kind of like a ghost of the bear,
like the spirit of the bear and it's trying to leave the bear's body.
It's trying to like venture out,
but it stuck.
And then the bear catches side of me.
And that's the crazy,
another crazy thing about seeing these beings.
It's like the bear like turns to look at me and like notices me,
you know,
it's not like he was waiting for me there.
He's like,
Oh,
here you are.
You know,
like you just showed up.
So he turns to me and he goes,
I remember before this crown and all these chains when I was just a bear and I
could run free in the woods.
And I was like,
okay,
okay.
I got it.
And basically what he was trying his tell me was,
is that,
you know,
don't ever let money and wealth or anything tie you down and keep you from your
freedom and expressing what your real nature is,
you know,
and,
and really kind of like a Buddhist sentiment that he was telling a difficult
thing for Google to do.
It sounds like such a noble task when you're poor.
The real problem is once you actually get money,
you know,
one of the big things that happens with people and they get money as they say,
they're scared of not having money.
So they start doing things they think like,
um,
like they'll look,
especially I guess see this with comics.
They like start saying things they think people want to hear or they started,
uh,
you know,
like avoiding any sort of controversy that might get them in trouble or moving
away from anything that might be controversial because they want to keep this
money coming in.
Yeah,
I got a career now I'm got to keep my career coming and the bear becomes no
longer a bear.
And this analogy there got gold chains on looking like a retard.
Yeah,
exactly.
It does bear asking for a picnic bench,
but you might have it got rid of,
I didn't get real gay after that.
So at that point,
like I,
I dunno,
I somehow was able to like free the bears spirit after he said that and we went
like frolicking through the words,
it's yoga guys,
your boy,
where's my boy after that.
So we like cruise around and then the final visitation from this being as I was
cruising through the forest,
like hopping over logs.
It was very like Robin Hood,
cartoon style,
you know,
it'll John and Robin Hood and through the forest type of program and then sew
up,
you know.
And then all of a sudden I see an eagle up in the sky and I like raise my
consciousness to the eagle,
anything.
It was really like a dream state.
So anything's possible,
you know?
So I just kind of flowed up to the Eagle and Eagle looks at me and I'm cruising
along.
The Ego says,
do you know how I see so well?
And I said,
no.
He says,
because I see through everybody else's eyes and I took a moment to sink in and
what he was showing me there was that.
Also,
often when we try and imagine what people are thinking or feeling,
we have our own bias.
We don't actually truly see through their eyes,
like imagine what their fears and motivations and weaknesses,
even the people that we don't like.
We always see him with this kind of bias look like,
oh,
that dude's a fucking idiot.
But you know,
if we really try to get into their eyes,
you can learn something about that person and learn something about the world by
actually dropping all of your kind of own ego and really assuming the eyes of
whatever else you're,
you're trying to look at,
whether it's an animal or a person or something like that.
I've tried that.
I've tried that with a lot of people.
I try that,
especially with people that don't like,
yeah,
I was trying to figure out how they got the,
especially once I had kids,
I had kids and I started looking at people completely different cause I looked
at them as babies and become adults.
So looked at this weird process like I used to see someone who is weak and like
you,
it's your fucking weak bitch.
That's what I would think.
And now I love you.
See to do,
wow,
what happened?
How'd you get?
How'd you get to this spot where you don't,
you know what I'm going to encourage or you don't have any real whatever,
you know,
whatever it is or you hate or you're,
you're racist.
What it,
whatever's broken on you.
How'd you get there?
Yep.
And that's a really valuable way to do it.
And also I'm sure for a comedy,
you know,
you have to put yourself into the laughers eyes and consciousness to a certain
degree too.
Right?
I don't know,
man,
that I don't try to do.
Yeah.
I just try to do shit that I think is funny and they agree.
Cause I could not,
I mean,
as soon as it's too many people,
too much of a different swath of people.
Yeah.
And too many people have their own take on what's fun and what's not.
It's like what happens when you get a television show and a,
then you get a whole slew of producers that have an opinion over what the
character should be doing and what's funny and what's not funny.
Then it almost always goes to shit.
I mean,
so one strong voice sorta takes over.
It's very hard to express your own sense of humor.
I tried to express a sense of humors of a bunch of other funds or other random
people.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That makes sense.
But you know,
I guess so for me there was these three lessons from these three clearly,
seemingly,
you know,
different entities and uh,
and so yeah,
the question is,
you know,
were these part of my own consciousness teaching me these lessons are worthies
did they all have the same voice?
No,
the dragon
and the Dragon,
Rick close,
but they're,
the dragon was really,
I couldn't even mimic that voice.
It was like that booming.
Like you're too close to the festival speakers base kind of voice.
And the bear was just like,
like a man bear
man voice,
I don't know.
And the Eagle was ego was a little bit more normal,
but uh,
but yeah,
similar,
similar voices.
I mean,
if had to fuck one of those animals,
which one?
I find it just for pride.
I,
yeah,
just say you did it.
I find that that stone
themes reoccur with me over and over again,
just when I eat pot.
Those,
those,
those themes,
the themes of,
um,
of reality,
you know,
what are you,
what are your,
what's your real motivation when you're doing things?
What is your,
uh,
what's your real experience with other people and how much,
how much of like disputes that you have with people or how much of it is your
fault?
You know?
So I would think that if you take a hallucinogen,
you know,
I'm sure you have the same thoughts.
You know,
when you try,
if you try to better yourself,
you know,
if you're trying to move your life in a more positive direction,
you're going to have the same sort of key stumbling roadblocks.
I think in the,
in the mind,
like how much of my ego is holding me back?
How much of my perception of reality is distorted?
And that's holding me back.
So you would think that a drug,
if it was just something that would make you see Jesus or dragons,
you know,
that maybe that's what it is,
like these themes and that it's,
it's spelled out to you because the drug thinks you're an idiot.
It's like showing bare.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
It comes to you in a way that you kind of already,
it's,
I mean the,
I mean,
no,
I don't mean that in any disrespectful way at all.
But when I feel one of the things
I feel most certainly when I do a DMT or something along those lines,
it's done.
I'm a fucking idiot.
That's one of the humbling experience.
It's very,
I was extremely humbled after those visitations.
Cause you think that you got it all right.
And then it shows you someone like the dragon comes along and just,
it's like,
ah,
nobody like you were a little off.
So here's the truth.
And now come to terms with it.
You're like,
oh shit,
you can't have it.
Right.
It's part of being a human,
you know the,
like the Dalai Lama doesn't even get a lane.
He doesn't have it.
Right.
Got that.
Now he doesn't ever,
right.
Yeah.
He's ever got and he doesn't fuck.
Fuck.
He doesn't get his dick sucked.
Yeah.
It doesn't get his balls.
And that's why he's not an effective leader.
How are you fully gonna Trust?
I don't think he eats meat either.
He can go fuck himself.
Do you think of like those crazy homeless people though that are sitting there
talking,
having full on conversations with dragons,
do you think that's,
there's a big connection to actually feeling that and seeing that and opening
your brain up to that,
to that guy 20 years?
It's a real good question really.
And you'd be
disingenuous to,
to not address it because I think the,
what we said before that what's going on with those people in our medical idea,
you know,
the medical communities,
uh,
version of it is that there's an imbalance or a chemical imbalance.
They have issues,
they have whatever it is,
they're psychotic,
they're there,
you know,
paranoid schizophrenia,
whatever the diagnosis is,
we're going out on a limb and that there's some sort of chemicals
that are out of whack there.
Well,
it's the brain's just a soup of chemicals.
It's in the neuro transmitters,
receivers,
whatever the fuck the brain itself is,
the neurons,
all of it together mushing around.
If one of those is out of whack,
you know,
and one of those is out of whack because you crazy.
Or one of those at a rack because you were at the,
at a hut in the fucking jungle.
Right.
He took some crazy shit,
which is a soup of some roots that fucking blow your neurotransmitter levels out
of the water,
like Shit's coming out of your ears.
I mean,
what is,
what was really happening there is that might not be much different than what
that guy is experiencing at the bus stop.
Well,
I mean the con,
the quality of content is actually there.
Your brain is a healthy brain can bring you back to baseline on a DMT flash in
15 minutes.
I WASC is a little longer because it's absorbed by the stomach and so it's sort
of a slower process.
The what,
what owe Osca is,
is an orally active version of dimethyl trip to me,
which is the most powerful psychedelic drug known demand,
which is also produced by your own brain.
Yeah.
That's the weirdest part about it is that it's an,
all these different plants.
It's like in grass and all these fucking leaves and squirrels make it.
It's everywhere.
That is,
there's a small amount and everything.
The leaves that they choose.
In the jungle,
they choose the leaf called Chacruna,
which is one of the strongest DMT containing plants and in the jungle.
But actually there's other plants like the Acacia plant from Australia,
which has an even much higher DMT content.
You can make an Iowasca out of other different things.
Like you could use a Syrian rue and Acacia to make a different IOWASCA type
period.
You have a different quality visual experience.
Well that was one of the things they say about the um,
uh,
the idea of the psychedelic experience is that when you're taking it,
you're taking in the experiences of all the other people who've also experienced
a psychedelic drug.
And as you do mushrooms,
you are actually contributing to the library of mushroom experiences.
Yeah.
The collective unconscious of all of that becomes the spirit of the mushroom or
the spirit of the IOWASCA.
That's generally how they talk about it.
You know where else that acacia bushes in large quantities?
Israel.
Oh yeah.
Oh the,
what they believed was the burning Bush that Moses is.
Scholars believe that's legitimate guys who aren't even psychedelic scholars.
Cause those are slippery scholars,
some of them,
some of them a little sketchy.
But um,
this,
there's a recent thing where these guys from,
uh,
some major university in Jerusalem,
we're talking about how they believe that Moses receiving the 10 commandments
from God and God taking the form of the burning Bush was most likely a Bush that
contained psychedelic chemicals like smoking the Acacia Bush.
Makes Sense.
It totally makes so many of those mystical make perfect sense if you put them in
a psychedelic drug perspective.
I mean,
that is the most obvious one ever though.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's a burning Bush.
The non,
they're not calling it anything else.
It's a burning Bush.
It,
it just so happens to the Acacia Bush as the highest concentration of DMT,
any plan in the world.
And it grows all over the fucking place.
Right.
Where this dude saw God,
you know what Bush did think it was burning.
It was probably that Bush.
I bet if you burn a bush and fucking got over it and sucked it all in,
I bet you would see the same shit,
Moses.
Especially if you were hungry and you're walking around fasting or balls off
anyway.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I think a great many of the rich religious experiences that people have had can
be connected to psychedelics including like Mayan art and Egypt ardor.
Cause one of the creepiest things that I've found is that,
especially on mushrooms,
I,
I've seen a lot of like Mayan things.
I've seen like a lot of like mine imagery and like freshly painted Mayan
hieroglyphs like you see that sort of imagery and you wonder what came first,
the chicken or the egg because you know these motherfuckers reading mushrooms
like crazy.
I mean they were living in the jungle where these things grow.
They look like dinner plates if you've ever seen them in Mexico had one of the
richest traditions of,
of mushroom news.
Sure.
You know,
that's where Gordon Wasson first found out about it and all these different
Sharman in Mexico take people on these journeys to the spirit world using these,
these,
these fucking dinner plate sized mushrooms.
That's one.
The interesting thing about the psychedelics and make it seem like it's not your
mind,
but like someone can take Iowasca anywhere in the world that desert,
the mountains,
the city,
whatever,
and they're almost always going to have similar visions of snakes and the jungle
and these different banners.
Jaguar's always goes back to the jungle and you know,
how is that,
how is that possible?
If it's just solely being mind creative,
it seems like that's where it gets weird and that's why even with these beings,
like,
you know,
I was laughing with uh,
with Mitch Schultz.
I was talking to him the other day and uh,
and we are saying,
you know,
if the Lebron James of I Wasco came along,
he could go to these entities and figuring out what they do when they're not
teaching people shit,
you know,
if they're real.
Because whenever they appear,
they're always trying to teach you something or tell you something like,
what are they doing today?
Like hang out and play around like play board games or like what do they do in
their life?
Like,
how do you get to that point where you can experience more than just taking a
lesson?
And that would be the way to determine whether these are just,
you know,
ways that your mind is communicating with itself or whether these things have a
life outside of this didactic purpose that they have.
It feels like you're popping your head into somewhere.
You're not supposed to be.
It does.
It really feels like you're like,
oh,
what am I doing here?
And they're like,
what are you doing here?
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh,
you're back.
It's weird that they communicate with you.
And sometimes in sentences and words you've heard before,
it might be a delay in your inner,
you know,
how you
can,
like if you listen to your inner conscious talking and imagined the drug just
slows down your ability to,
uh,
received your inner conscious voice.
And so it sounds like it's somebody else,
but it's really yourself and your inner conscious talking to yourself.
It could be,
yeah,
it could mean it could be a lot of different things for sure.
You know,
um,
I think one of the first DMT trips that I had,
one of the weirdest feelings about it all was that the idea of being connected
to everything sounds like such fucking hippie bullshit.
It sounds like nonsense.
You know,
say we are here,
but we are connected to everything.
It's,
I'm not feeling that,
you know,
I don't,
I know that that might be real,
but for whatever reason,
I don't really feel that.
I don't feel the subatomic particles.
I don't feel the Adam,
I don't feel the cell.
I don't,
I just feel me and I know that I'm breathing air,
but I don't feel the fact that the air is connected to the,
all these,
it's all a soup of things.
But when you have the DMT experience,
one of the things that it does is it strips whatever you're experiencing while
you're tripping your balls off.
It strips away the physical presence of things.
And it's almost like the world of,
you know,
here's the ground,
here's the air and here's a tree and here's a building.
That world is replaced by a world where nothing has any matter.
Nothing has any physical matter,
but everything is everywhere.
Everything is everywhere and you're in the middle of it and there's no ends and
there's no beginning.
There's no roof,
there's no floor.
It's just one thing.
It's all a part of one thing and you're in there scrambling,
trying to make sense of it.
And these things come out of nowhere that are essentially constantly changing as
you're watching them.
So you're not even sure what the fuck it actually is.
And you know,
it might be your own mind.
It might be you're my own mind trying to make sense of the whole thing,
but they're trying to give you information.
One of the things that I tried to tell you,
you to try to stop,
don't freak out and try to suck it all in.
Try to take in as much as you can because we know this is crazy.
And um,
and they tell you they love you too.
That's like,
it's always a big thing.
Like love you.
Like the one experiences that I had,
they sang to me like a child.
They had this song,
I love you.
600 million,
500,000 times,
which is like how a kid would say something and then we'd go look at this and
they would show me something fucking insane.
Something where you couldn't look at it like it was too beautiful to look at and
then it would say it again like I love you 600 million,
500,000 times,
look at this.
And every time it was looking at this like I was crying,
I remember crying cause what I was looking at was too impossible to,
to nothing could be that beautiful.
And every time they would say,
look at this,
it would get a million times more beautiful.
That was,
it was just taking my breath away.
I couldn't breathe.
It was like,
it was very,
very strange.
But it was,
it was very,
very,
very positive.
The experience all over was very pops and so much of it was like,
dude,
relax.
Yeah,
Like this whole thing is first of all way beyond your control way big and new
thing and it's going to be fine.
Like that was like those,
like a big,
a big theme that if anything that I learned from it,
I learned that I learned,
I think a d I got,
I think DMT made me a nicer person.
I think I learned how to chill out more.
Sure.
It's really valuable that way actually that just speaking about what you were
saying that so the third time I drunk,
I didn't have any particularly crazy visions,
but for three hours I like the,
at the hut that I was in,
everything else melted away and I felt myself dissolve into the floor of the
jungle and I was like,
yeah,
the bugs and the worms were crawling through me like the air was,
it was like I was no longer a physical being and I was absolutely one with the
gentleman and I was asking,
I was like,
Hey,
does the dragon want to show up?
Just anybody want to come.
But nobody wanted to come.
It was just like literally three hours just breathing with the jungle.
And I left that and I was like,
it was just a really grounding and connecting experience.
But it was almost at that point,
I think the message to me was like,
you know,
we're done teaching you silly little lessons.
Like,
you know,
take this,
be grounded,
be humbled,
be connected,
and go off and do,
you know,
do your work.
Do what you need to do.
I was his version of kids together,
bitches.
Yeah.
It was,
it was just really so peaceful.
And so,
but I remember it,
you know,
all of the things that normally would creep me out,
the creepy crawlers of the jungle,
you know,
you look at the ground in the jungle and it's alive,
and there's ants and all kinds of shit.
That was,
that was me,
that was in my body and I was just totally relaxed and disintegrated.
And that was a really kind of powerful medicinal effect.
Vine of thorn sliding down a vine of thorns naked naked.
That was the fucked up.
I was like,
why do I gotta make it?
Like,
why does it take my genitals first?
Like what reason is just shredding,
shredding them.
How much are you in?
You don't feel the physical pain,
but you,
you have that kind of horror,
the horror of your genitals being mutilated as you sliding down the line,
a thorn so it can get intense,
but you get just got to,
you got to remove yourself from that kind of an angst,
you know,
and just witness and allow,
that's the mantra anybody is going through any of these experiences.
Just witness it and allow it to happen.
Wow.
Whatever it may be.
But you know,
I,
the last experience I did was the Boga experience.
And this one really kind of drew some counterpoints to those two experiences.
They're so wildly different.
And I think I touched on this last time because I was fresh from a Boga,
but um,
I was couple show you some things that you have no fucking clue what it means.
Like one of the visions I had after the drag and the bear that you go,
cause I was on this viking ship and it was rolling through this.
See this moonlit see,
you know,
I'm like,
all right,
sweet.
I'm on this ship,
I don't know what's going on.
And then all of a sudden the ship peels out and heads straight towards the moon.
So we're going straight towards this giant blue moon and this moon line is like
bathing me.
And then this purple orb comes drifting out of the moon and it's drifting
towards me,
drifting towards me,
and I opened my mouth and I eat it just,
and then I was like,
wow,
that was significant.
That must have done something,
but nothing happened.
I don't know what it was.
It was about your balls off.
That was it.
And then the whole time,
even to this day,
I mean the best explanation I had was maybe it had something to do with like the
feminine energy,
the mood,
but I don't fucking know.
I have no clue if that had any meaning at all.
Or if it was just some random trip.
Did you sit in a feminine energy or the Moon?
Why would you think of the movie?
You don't know?
I don't know.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm
just reaching for straws.
I mean,
that's a fully,
it is feminine.
Loves that,
that,
that feeling,
that way of distinguishing things.
The Feminine Energy of the forest.
Yeah.
Who knows?
But you know,
but that's the difference between a Bogan,
like a Bogo will tell you like,
hey,
what,
it doesn't bother with the pictures of this strange moon and this purple orb and
be like,
Yo,
this is the truth.
Like,
and it's in kind of your own voice,
but I have Watsco will give you things.
I mean,
some things were very poignant and you know,
taught me a lesson,
like the things with the allies,
but there's all these other visions that you're left,
like what the fuck was that can be.
It can be a challenge in,
in some of that,
some of that regard.
But the physical experience you feel,
how connected you feel,
how cleanse do you feel?
Because afterwards,
after that third session,
he took one of his cigarettes,
the nicotine year ristic uh,
cigarettes and he blew it like down my spine and like on the top of my head and
in different key parts.
And I was like,
I wasn't even that nauseous that whole time.
The third time I felt very comfortable.
I got back to the room and just fucking lost it.
Like I felt like I was heaving some giant ball of something from like the depths
of my soul.
I don't know what was going on.
It hit my mouth so hard that I exploded.
Vomit from my mouth and my nose.
And there's nothing worse than stomach acid and old iowasca blasting out of your
nose at the same time.
And at the same time my eyes are watery.
It can hardly see it.
There's no electricity in the bathroom cause we're,
you know,
there's the,
they run the generator like three hours.
So then I have to like turn around and like blast some shit in the toilet too.
And it's like this brutal like savage cleanse.
Wow.
And I,
and that somehow it seemed triggered by whatever kind of,
you know,
cigarette cleansing thing he did the next day.
Cause I saw him the next morning and he just had this big smile on his face and
he asked me in his broken English and Spanish,
you know,
how was last night?
And I was like,
what the fuck man?
Like these like tobacco and just nods and laps and pat me pats me on the back
and keeps the tobacco makes you throw up and shit yourself.
I don't know.
I mean whether it,
the tobacco is a vehicle for some kind of trigger or whether it itself did
something,
whatever it happened.
I had like the most
intense purge that I've ever had in my life,
like savage and that was his intention while doing it.
So was it mental?
It does have a different,
maybe it wasn't tobacco,
you know,
maybe that was when he like tobacco,
it was really some kind of pointers,
but it was,
it was potent.
And that's a,
that's something that I think that's why they call it the master medicine
because you feel like you purge all of these different poisons from your body.
Jesus Christ.
It seems like you should be able to do that in America.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So ridiculous.
You have to get on a canoe to do this.
Absolutely.
You know,
all the way to Peru people to do.
She's a little to get a nice hotel,
get a steak consumer,
nice.
A resort.
It's just,
it's really preposterous.
I mean,
to think that people would be abusing,
it's not fucking fun.
It's valuable.
It's Madison.
It's like you do it with,
uh,
you know,
with,
with intention.
Nobody gets through it unscathed.
You're going to learn something.
It's like,
I don't,
I've never heard of anybody that has had like a real deep psychedelic journey
that didn't come back and go,
wow,
I gotta fucking rethink everything.
I'm never,
I don't know anybody that has a real one,
you know?
I mean,
if you,
if you don't,
Jesus Christ,
what fucking hope is there for you?
Right.
You know?
Alright,
you goddamn Dullard
if you're a,
you know,
if you're able to do that in cities,
if there was places where you could go get your shit together,
we'd have way more people with their shit together.
Totally.
We really,
what's the counter balance?
It's like the way to counterbalance all of this,
you know,
living in an apartment and grinding and strip malls and end to doing shit.
You don't lie.
Don't cheat.
You don't like because it doesn't,
it doesn't mean that every,
you know,
everybody can't live the perfect life.
But guess what?
You're not everybody.
Okay?
The world's going to keep going as,
as it always has,
with or without you.
It's going to be going and it was too many.
You're not that important,
okay?
So if,
if that is the case,
it is possible for you.
You,
the individual.
Then again,
this whole thing might be your imagination.
I might be a creation of your imagination as you hear this.
I might not even exist,
okay?
I might be here just to get these words into your mind to,
so somehow or another usic left when everybody wants you to Zig,
right?
You know,
there's just,
maybe that's what it is and I'm not skeptical.
Why not?
Real?
I'm not real.
I am real Joe Rogan.
Goddammit.
You're real.
And the influence for you to,
to stray from the herd,
you know,
you know how they,
uh,
there was an old debate,
you know,
that was,
that was a popular debate for a while amongst philosophers.
Are we real?
How do you know if we're real?
And there was a famous case where one philosopher,
someone was,
you know,
going off on that how you have no,
you don't know that you're really,
you don't know that I'm real,
whatever.
And he takes off his glove and he slaps the guy slaps the guy across the face.
It was like,
was that real?
And that kind of in my fucking needed that guy in his imaginary worlds on the
face and you're get anything done.
That's the,
that's the only way you can effectively combat that argument.
Weird idea,
man.
I mean you think about your,
you're tripping your balls off and Iowasca and certain people are seeing Jesus,
you know,
and then other people are seeing jaguars and they're seeing things they're
scared of or things that seem that they revere these ideas.
I am not convinced that the imagination only has the power to create things then
manifest them in the real world with actions.
It might have a secondary power and might be have an actual power of creation.
I don't know what the fuck happens when you leave my house.
I'm pretty sure you're getting your car and you go to your life and you'd go and
do your thing and hanging out with your girlfriend and getting your car and,
and I'm pretty sure you do the same thing,
but I'm not positive.
I'm not really positive about any of this and I'm not positive that as you move
in a certain direction that you know you're there,
you're the same person every step of the way,
you're the same.
You,
there might be an infinite number of use with every single decision you make,
branches off into another you and another way and another version,
another reality and all these realities to intertwine with each other.
And then we meet,
you know,
that's why sometimes when you run into someone,
it's like you been on a path and you've been a journey and this motherfucker has
been on a different thing,
you know,
not the same as you,
less,
you know,
less self,
uh,
self objective,
less self analytical and you know,
maybe maybe self destructive and then you around them.
It's like,
how did I ever hang out with you?
Like you were,
we're live,
we live in a different world.
Kind of do,
maybe kind of do live in a different world.
Maybe you're,
I the idea that time is just one flat linear thing that we're all sort of living
our lives in and this one sort of band,
maybe that's not real.
Maybe it's like just like the DMT dimension.
Maybe it's just a fucking great big giant soup of potential universes that are
constantly shifting and we just flipped back and forth from one to the other and
move through them.
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's,
uh,
it's,
it's so hard to say.
I mean,
I,
I particularly like the paradigm that the Shamans have there,
in which case they describe,
you know,
all of these different dimensions,
dimensions as the layers of an onion and each person as a toothpick that's
pierce is all the different layers of the onion.
And so that you're occupied in your consciousness on the first tangible layers,
which encompassed the first through the fourth,
you know,
space and time basically.
That's what you're conscious of.
And then the fifth part of the toothpick,
as you move up to another layer,
that's the dream state.
That's the collective consciousness.
And then the sixth and seventh,
uh,
dimensions,
those have the disembodied nonhuman entities that you interact with.
Like the floats that I found were from the seven,
they would call it the dragon and other these other things that you see,
you know,
the people singing you child songs.
Those are beings of the sixth dimension.
And then the eighth dimension
is this kind of oversight dimension where you can actually manipulate all the
dimensions beneath it and see,
you know,
see everything.
It's like the highest vantage point where you can see and,
uh,
the dimension of imminent possibility where you can basically do what you're
saying with your imagination,
believe things into reality from the eighth dimension,
you know,
imagine things into reality.
Has anybody ever had an experience from the eighth dimension where they imagine
some reality and then manifested it and then wrote about it?
Um,
I,
this is where I shop.
Yeah.
The shamans,
the Shamans do you know and happen,
that's where they say they got the idea to create Iowasca and they get these,
they get these messages and these different herbal treatments and you know it's
from these eight dimension teachings that they have.
But you know,
again,
I think there hasn't been enough of that,
but it's because there's not enough fucking people who have the skills able to
do that to also not only get there but then communicate the idea to a mass
market.
You know what I mean?
It's just such a limited swath of people who are able to access that dimension a
and then B to have that to cross section that with the amount of people who
could then think of something,
bring something back and express it.
You starts to get really small numbers.
So
it's so funny how many people who are productive members of society who are
interested in personal growth,
who are all discipline,
getting their shit done,
would never consider doing drugs to further themselves.
They would never even consider the possibility.
And it sounds like bullshit.
It sounds like an excuse to do drugs.
But really the greatest leaps I've personally experienced have been out of
psychedelic trips for sure.
Absolutely.
You know,
I was watching that.
I've watched the Ray Kurzweil documentary transcendent man.
And you seen that one?
Yeah.
And,
uh,
it occurred to me,
you know,
he's always looking for these different technologies to answer some two basic
questions.
One,
he wants to conquer death,
and two,
he wants to kind of revive his father's memory.
I mean,
those are big overriding forces.
He also has a lot of altruistic goals and he's an absolute genius,
no doubt about it.
But he's overlooking some very basic technologies that have been around forever.
And these technologies are the psychedelics.
Like I really truly believe that you can look at those as a technology,
you know,
and the technology of Iowasca can get him over his fear of death and show him
that,
you know,
there is an eternal part of him and everybody that's going to extend past to
this meat sack that we're currently walking around in.
But he's ignoring that technology because he's bought into the lie that this is
a drug and this is bad,
you know?
And,
and the,
uh,
Boga technology could get him direct access to the memories of his father.
So even if he wasn't really talking to his father,
I haven't made up a decision as to whether you're actually accessing these
people are just conversing with their memory.
He's at least going to be able to access the memories that he's trying to bring
back through technology.
There'll be able to access them and be able to communicate with his father and
maybe have some Cathartic piece from those,
from those experiences.
But because you know,
some body in their higher knowledge and said,
oh,
these things are illegal in the United States where,
you know,
they're legal and different places,
but illegal here,
he's completely ignored those technologies and it's been,
you know,
something,
uh,
that's really sad for his life may be good for all of ours because he's been
rabidly pushing forward other technologies to get there.
And so he's advanced humankind dramatically where maybe he wouldn't have a feed
out of,
had access to these other things.
But it's really interesting how a genius like that can be so focused on one area
and then just ignore something that's so right there in front of them have been
around for thousands of years.
Well it's almost impossible to know everything about everything.
I mean it is impossible to know everything about everything.
And you know,
a guy like that is obviously very driven and very successful and he's a,
he's a guy who works very hard and he's a very no nonsense sort of a guy.
And I think that guys like that they look at drugs as being a way to derail
yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a self indulgent sort of a self destructive activity.
Propaganda.
Yeah.
Poor fools.
Propaganda.
It's a,
it's a bummer.
I actually had another thought.
This is kind of changing the subject a little bit,
but I think I have my develop my own version of the singularity.
I think,
you know,
he has a very kind of technological kind of view of when that's going to happen,
when man and machine become indistinguishable.
And you know,
I follow a lot of what he's saying.
I think that,
you know,
I think that nanotechnology could eventually take over the immune
responsibilities and the computational responsibilities that we currently have.
Like I'm,
I'm fine with that.
Um,
but I don't believe that's really the singularity cause I certainly do believe
in an eternal part of us.
And I think that the real singularity is going to come when we advanced to the
stage where we can consciously take that eternal part and choose which body we
want to be in and whether we want to be in it or not.
So we,
that whole death,
you know,
the myth of death when we think we die and then we think it's all over,
it's really a transition when we transcend that and we can just take our spirit
and say,
okay,
I'm going to live in this body for a little while,
and then,
okay,
I'm done with that body.
I'll take the,
take my spirit and push it into another body.
And so that consciousness never experiences the memory loss,
never experiences that lack of connectedness with everything else.
I think for me,
you know,
that is that,
that is the true singularity.
And I think that singularity would come when the really pushed the advances in
this kind of psychedelic exploration.
You know,
I don't think that comes from technology.
Maybe we do after extend our lives another 500 years to be able to get there.
You know,
and technology can help us extend our lives for 500 years or whatever.
But I think ultimately the big advances that are going to take us to that
complete paradigm shifting level are going to come from,
you know,
manipulating molecules like DMT and how they interact with the brain and
transcending and being able to master these altered extra states of
consciousness.
Yeah,
I think that the technology is sort of a psychedelic experience.
It's just a really slow moving one.
But it's uh,
uh,
what,
what psychedelics do is they dissolve boundaries and they create the impossible
in front of you and that sort of humbling to the ego and provide you with a
limitless source of information.
That's the Internet.
I mean,
the Internet,
the Internet that is psychedelic defined,
the Internet is Psychedelic,
you know,
it's just,
it's not a big hallucination.
So we sort of mistake the concept of what,
what is psychedelic,
but the technology for sure is changing everything and providing people with
things that to them will be a regular part of their everyday life.
But just a hundred years ago were impossible and science fiction and insane,
you know?
And then it just becomes normal and you just get used to it.
If we stay alive for a million years,
what does this going to look like?
I mean,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it will look psychedelic it,
it'll look like a goddamn DMT flash.
The world will look like something that we can't even wrap our heads around.
We all have Google goggles on and we're walking around reading each other's
Auras and you know,
there's new scanners that they're introducing it,
the TSA that are going to be able to a scan what you've had to eat that day.
Like literally there'll be something like that for like drug meals that are
swapping for everything.
Not only that,
well,
they'll be able to tell if people are high,
they'll be able to tell if you're intoxicated,
if you're drunk,
if you're on pot,
whatever,
they'll,
they'll be able to scan.
Oh yeah.
Well that's what it is.
This lack of privacy is no longer a problem,
but it's now reality.
It's,
it's,
it's slowly changing from,
you know,
like what are we going to do when the government can read your email?
Two,
everyone's going to be able to read your email.
You know,
it's,
there's not going to be any information that you can share or that you can hide.
Rather,
it's going to get to a point where every thought that you ever have is able to
be accessed.
It's going to be ones and Zeros at the brick in the wall.
It's going to finally reached the convergence.
That's the real technological singularity,
right?
The idea that we all converge,
but not,
not,
not with some something malicious bad parent running the fucking show like,
well,
like we have right now.
Yeah.
We gotta figure that out.
That's,
that's got,
uh,
they've,
they have to catch the fuck up because the only reason why there are malicious
parents,
cause they're ignorant.
They haven't had those experiences,
which is why I've said before like you should never be a fucking president or
any kind of leader unless you've had a massive psychedelic experience.
People say that.
That's ridiculous.
I mean to the uninitiated,
me saying that,
it's like,
oh that's rogue and being silly.
You know,
he's just talking nonsense.
The fucking cage fighting commentator electric stream shit.
No,
but no rationally you like,
who the fuck are you to try to change the world once you haven't improved the
world?
You don't even think that you're going to just keep playing the same stupid.
See what
the fucking dragon has to say about indefinite detention.
And we do love to see Barack Obama just a fucking hut filled with Barack Obama,
George Bush Jr George Bush,
Sr Wolfowitz Rumsfeld and there were all Iowasca isn't it?
They would be puking out little fucking demon.
I'd rather see my next,
yeah,
what a nice thing that I got.
I mean,
there'll be nice to each other for a few hours and they have headaches and
fucking knew somebody for it.
Then the Serotonin all deplete themselves.
More cranky than ever.
But if you got them on like a real session of five,
five or six session,
month long journey,
take a leave them out there and at the end of it,
how do you feel Mr Wolfowitz?
Yeah.
Just thinking about all the millions of desks they've caused,
it could have been avoided.
All the babies their rack with no,
they may not come back from the jungle.
They may feel like they just fucking can't.
They're going to go for a walk until a Jaguar get some.
It's it sacrifice himself in a Jaguar.
I probably wouldn't get Dick Cheney.
Am I gonna do with this old motherfucker Jaguar people that are that old.
Yeah.
This is poison old cheeseburger.
Eaton Douche bag probably smells like ass.
Imagine a lot of the bad smells to a Jaguar.
Yeah.
Couldn't be good on his second heart
became as would get them fuck came will eat anything.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
they will,
right?
Yeah.
They don't get that bag though,
dude.
They're not too big.
How big is that?
They're not that scary day.
They can get like 10 feet,
10 feet,
10 feet could kill you.
But they're not that.
They're not that aggressive.
They're not like crocodile than not like the crocs.
It's weird how parts of the world,
like some parts just developed too much cattle.
The develop too many onion animals,
too many hooved animals.
And they're like,
all right,
bring in the monsters.
I'm going to get the monsters have to chase down these 50 mile an hour running
cows and kill these fucking things.
I mean,
everywhere you look that has too many cows.
Too many,
too many,
whatever it is.
Whether it's antelope or water buffalo,
there's crocodiles,
there's Willdabeast,
there's lions is,
it's all like,
it's almost like nature.
Go stop.
Just does she fuck you fucking cunts.
He won't stop being stopped.
Fucking eating grass.
All right.
Bring it in and send the monsters.
But in,
you know,
in the Amazon there's no cattle,
so they're like cam little crocodiles,
little ones.
Will Caymans snaking clean up the fish snakes.
We don't,
we don't have like herds of cattle wandering through the fall rain forest.
But you have to minimize,
no,
there is a very,
you do get a very balanced sense,
you know like black at nature.
Got It right there.
When you're in the jungle,
you know,
like every inch is covered in life and the life is all kinds of working
together.
It's pretty,
it's a pretty cool feeling.
Sad as fuck.
When you fly over the areas that have been chewed up,
we,
we into Brazil and there's areas we fly over,
we can see where they've uh,
chopped down big swaths of the rain forest and it's like wow,
that's no joke.
Like that's a lot.
Like they,
they've cut a lot of fucking trees down man.
And that rain forest is not growing back where they cut it down.
I mean it's not,
it doesn't grow back there.
It doesn't,
it dries up and that's it.
It needs the more,
I mean it's like a self sustaining sort of an environment.
The rain forest is and when you chop it down,
it's not like it just builds back up.
Now that ground gets dry there cause it's constantly exposed to the sun.
It changes everything.
It changes the whole ballgame.
It's really a,
it's really sad.
It's really kind of fucked up.
How many years would it take to grow that back?
Eventually we'd grow back it seven and it would it eventually?
I mean,
what did they go?
Well I don't know if it would,
I mean I think,
you know where the Nile Valley is used to be at one point in time.
A rain forest.
Yeah.
This would be the last look at it now.
It didn't grow back.
It became fucking sand desert weather patterns might add something to do with
that,
but I was watching a fucked up documentary on the and talls that may or may not
be bullshit.
Seems like it's bullshit.
According to a lot of these,
uh,
science people have debunked it,
but it's really cool.
It's too bad that it's bullshit because the,
uh,
he wrote this thing about neanderthals,
that we sort of,
um,
I think the word is anthropomorphize.
You,
uh,
sort of give animals human characteristics,
right.
And,
uh,
he compares a human skull and the Anatol Scott,
it's really fascinating that,
that,
first of all,
you know,
we,
we've seen images of neanderthals.
They always looked like people kind of caveman.
Yeah,
exactly.
But just like Ari on a bad day.
But we're very different looking than neanderthals.
Neanderthals have much larger eyes and they're much higher on her head.
They're like,
where our forehead is.
Yeah.
It's weird.
There.
Look,
they would look weird as fuck.
If you saw a neanderthal in front of you,
it wouldn't be like,
oh,
there's a dude,
you know,
that's on his way to the movies.
He'd be like,
what the fuck is going on there?
Right.
And this guy made them out.
Like the other thing is that,
um,
you know,
we always assume they have white skin and uh,
he made versions of them like a artificial version of where they had black skin
like a gorilla and they were super muscular and you know,
his ideas that it was a,
we were at war with neanderthals until the intelligent humans figured out how
to,
uh,
how to overcome them.
But like,
look at one of the images is this mother fucker put up his idea of what a,
a neanderthal face would look like.
Yeah.
And he's like,
they would have big like slit eyes like a cat.
So they could see at night their eyes were much larger than ours and they were
using tools and they were intelligent and they probably hunted out.
It's like Avatar.
It looks fucking fat ass.
But apparently there's very little little to support this guy's theories and
it's,
he's most likely gone silly
and went like super sensationalist with all this.
But uh,
it is kind of cool.
Was a terminal chain of its own in evolutionary,
like the branch.
Then apps that created homosapiens happened earlier and then neanderthals with
some terminal node that died out.
Right.
Well they would want both from neanderthals.
Anything.
Exactly.
Well,
we will see it's,
I dunno,
it's all very sketchy,
but neanderthals evolved in Europe.
Homosapiens evolved in Africa.
That's what we know.
But we also know that a lot of people have a certain percentage of neanderthals
in them,
so we don't know what happened there,
whether we fuck them or they fly us or both or both.
But if they looked like this,
it would be pretty freaky if they're really did look like giant gorillas.
How many people wanted to fuck the blue avatar chick?
I mean people went there first.
They're a big crazy blue bedroom.
Especially if you could be in that big blue body being dude's body.
She was sexy man.
Something about us.
The NAVI.
Yeah.
How many people got depressed after they saw that movie and wanting to live in
the avatar world?
No where that is.
It was definitely,
I did look down with,
but that was like a real issue with people.
They've got an Avatar depressure sure.
We still long for that.
That sort of noble hunter gatherer existence,
you know,
and we still want it and that and the connectedness,
the sense of tribe.
We have a,
we have no fucking sense of tribe anymore.
I really,
you know,
we're so just as a tribe,
as we get a couple of friends and we don't even live near each other,
he has to drive a fucking,
I see him four days a week.
He'd tribes like an hour to get here.
Yeah,
exactly.
Imagine if you had a walk.
We're nowhere near our friends and that's,
and that's so,
you know,
I think that's so important and so much of what's what's missing and allows
people to get so fucking off.
I saw it,
I was just going,
I was walking through a TV and I hate seeing local new shit.
And it talked about some dude who had his wife like chained up and was like
beating her with the hot frying pan.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck eight hearing that it makes me so mad.
But I'm thinking like,
you know,
if there was a tribe,
if that meant that only exists because he was allowed to live out on a farm and
nobody fucking checked on him.
But if you were in a try,
that shit doesn't happen.
You know?
It's like,
where's your wife?
I haven't seen it for 10 years.
You know,
you're fucking hissing and screaming like you can't you,
there's a some kind of stuff the tribe would have taken care of.
That guy,
you know,
had been like,
you are fucking sick.
Dot.
Go back to the source.
Like you're done,
you're done.
You know?
And,
and that just doesn't happen.
There's no kind of,
and that's an extreme example.
I mean,
easier examples are the people who were bummed out and depressed and can't talk
to anybody or can't do anything or can't have that social contact.
I saw something else on that.
I think it's dissimilar.com site where this woman started a,
a service where she's charging like $60 to snuggle for like an hour,
you know?
And,
and like a New Yorker.
So you're going to get raped.
People are so fucking isolated from other human contact that it's seriously
depressing state dollars to snuggle,
snuggle,
want that snuggling.
Some people need it mad.
She's teasing.
If she's hard to do it,
60 bucks,
of course you would do it,
but you would try to fucker.
Maybe you see this bullshit.
Maybe they're hookers currently just with maybe going,
but I know,
I know that I put out a cop,
like if you take a baby monkey away from the human contact of the,
of the mother monkey,
you know the big can't like hug up on it.
They've done studies about that and the monkey gets fucked up.
It's like a terrifying,
it's all fucking whacked out.
Yeah.
You know,
I think a certain amount of contact and interaction is what our species is made
for.
And isn't it ironic that the larger the species group gets,
the less contact it has with each other?
I mean,
you would think that there's 300 million of us fog would be interacting with
each other at all.
They long constantly never get away from each other.
It's almost like the technology is trying to bring us closer to a tribe.
Technology by dissolving secrets in boundaries is trying to bring this gigantic
group back together again as one,
as as one individual unit,
like a tribe.
But I think that there's a weird problem that we have with the fact that
technology is just fucking taking off faster than our biology can catch up to.
I agree.
You know,
and I don't,
I don't,
I think it's real hard for people to be happy in the reality of today's world
because just physiologically,
well first of all,
monogamy,
you know,
how many people struggle with monogamy?
How many people struggle with,
uh,
you know,
the idea of a,
the responsibility of being a parent.
How many people struggle with the idea of the,
you know,
the fact that you have to sustain some sort of a living in existence.
It's,
it all seems like something you don't want to do,
but yet this is what everybody's doing.
Everybody's getting the house and paint.
You got 30 year commitment to pay x amount a month and you've got to work or
they're fucking take all your,
your house away and everything get paid,
we'll go to nothing and you're fucking doomed.
I mean,
you look at the way a lot of people are forced to live this life.
It's so completely and totally unnatural,
but so completely an obviously designed to keep this machine moving in the same
direction because you keep this machine mass producing technology,
mass producing innovation and moving at faster and faster and further and
further.
I mean that ultimately everybody's like a little worker bee trying to push their
segment of technology further.
Yeah.
But it's the content starting to reject it.
You know what I mean?
You're starting to see the casual,
the casualties have been around for a long time.
He's filled those with antidepressants.
Yeah.
Keep them in the system,
keep him going.
But at a certain point people are going to get fucking fed up again.
And I think that's maybe what this whole change in consciousness that people are
talking about.
I think that enough.
I think that actually may be real.
I don't know if it has anything to do with what the mines were talking about,
but you can kind of sense something different now.
Well,
I think just the fact that we're,
we've been bombarded with truth for the past,
you know,
who knows how many years now.
Yeah.
We're constantly bombarded with reality and information and this is just such a
strange time where there's no running from reality.
Whereas before people could just sort of live in the dark or go super religious
or you know,
they could block themselves off to giant chunks of what really makes the world
tick.
Can't do that anymore.
Now it's,
it's all sorts of people are becoming too empowered.
They're too,
too filled with information to aware and it's slowly starting to see how it's
balancing itself out in the financial world.
Like people are going to jail like crazy.
Yeah.
Lawsuits are coming down like crazy.
There's it,
you can't hide information the way it used to.
You couldn't,
that Bernie Madoff,
dude,
that guy,
that guy could have rock that shit for a hundred years back in 1910 you know,
and he could a rock that shit until the wheels fell off and no one would've
suspected it.
Common.
But in this world and today's Day and age,
it's like it's not that easy.
Yeah.
It'll be interesting to see which way it goes.
I think there is a yearning said,
I don't know if he could've rocked that shit in 1910 I think.
I mean they would have probably caught him either way.
I don't think that,
I think there's a yearning to get back to that kind of community sense.
I mean,
as you said,
while you can connect with a massive amount of people online,
I mean so much of the interaction is also pretty fucked up too.
You know,
and it,
you feel,
it's not like interacting with a real person where that,
where you would never say that to another person because you would see him a,
even if you were stronger and could kick their ass,
you would see him get sad and there would be like,
you'd feel bad hopefully,
unless you're just a fucking total monster.
But you know,
there's this check and balance of real interaction versus cyber interaction that
yeah.
Feelings that you get from talking to people.
You can just anonymize and honesty and lash out at someone with no repercussions
whatsoever.
Yeah.
Have you been to the county fair?
That's all it's about.
You know,
there were so many fucking people out.
It's just stupid people out there,
you know,
and you really see it.
Yeah.
Like if you go to like a hometown,
Midwest County Fair
people just having fun,
man,
there's going to be a few decades.
But whenever you get large gatherings of people,
there's always a few decades,
but that's not most of them.
Peop uh,
go to the county fair in Ohio,
because Ohio is a different world.
It wasn't totally a different world in Los Angeles,
but how was it a different world as far as the county fair?
It's just,
just go there,
I guess.
It's just awful in a few rodeos and they're pretty friendly people.
Yeah.
What do you experience the dumbness,
the caveman type species that lives in certain areas of the United States where
your soul,
Ohio was mostly audience?
Is that what we're saying?
There's a lot of them.
There's was a lot of them.
So when you go to a state fair in Ohio,
you think you'd just seen a lot it cause,
I mean
there might be Columbus,
there might be Cleveland and there might be Cincinnati,
but there's a whole lot of other space around those areas that you are like,
Oh,
who lives here?
I think the majority,
at least 80% of them are cool.
I think you're just,
you're dealing with a small group of loud people that you know come a problem
almost everywhere.
And a lot of them are fucking,
probably what I'm saying though is the hawks and hate their life.
And what I'm saying though is that if you see these people that are just idiots
and retarded on online that are just yelling out con fuck blah blah,
those are the same people that you see.
You know the worst,
the worst.
You see those people in real life too.
You just never see them.
Cause we're here in Los Angeles.
Well not just that because you avoid them because you've got a good social
circle,
you know,
you know where to go and where not to go and every now and then it crosses over
and you wind up hanging out with,
some morons are getting stuck with some morons.
That's why I fucking wish that the states had full autonomy because I think you
would start to actually at that point where federal government could give up the
states,
could make cool enough laws and have a cool enough system built together,
kick counts out.
Well they would,
you know,
people would be attracted the right people,
they could be like a message board.
Just band people in real life.
Like that sense of tribe I think would come back.
You know,
there'd be a unity between the governing body and the people and they would be
like,
I fucking love my state.
Like not just from some strange patriotic pride,
like yeah,
you don't mess with Texas.
Eventually you're going to be able to walk up to someone and in like mouse over
them,
you'd be able to like put your cursor over them and you'll be able to read all
their information.
Hopefully that he would like lying motherfuckers.
Hopefully we'll have Yelp for people and you'll just see,
oh,
Aubrey has five stars.
He's a really cool guy.
We could take him anywhere.
And we still,
a California is only letting fivestar people in.
If you're a Douche bag,
you can't go.
And you know,
and this guy shows up.
Well I'm fucking good crews,
Jude.
I'm a good guy.
As long as you're not,
again,
trying to get mad.
And you see he's got two stars.
Like come on,
there's people on Yelp that,
I don't know how they got on there,
but there's people on Yelp and there were people revealing people like as if
they were a business.
But there's people on it.
Oh,
that's funny.
I haven't checked to see if I was on there,
but,
well,
you should be able to review the person that's reviewing and this the person
reviewing only us two stars.
You shouldn't,
you shouldn't count on like when she's a con.
Look,
of course she hates me.
She hates herself.
She hates everybody.
Can't category.
Speaking of hate ever Mao,
everybody would just fucking cheat that system.
Do you know this Daniel Tosh situation?
Do you know what happened with Daniel and I talked about it?
Yeah.
We didn't talk about this and this is what's hilarious is a woman wrote a blog
about this.
She wrote,
she's Tosh 2.0 or whatever.
That guy.
Yeah,
he's,
he's getting in trouble for this.
He's forced to apologize.
This asshole and this woman wrote a blog about it.
It completely delusional blog.
By the way.
He's asking this is what Daniel Tosh did.
He asked.
He asked what is,
she said,
oh,
I would find it.
This is Daniel Tosh.
The time I thought he was just some Yahoo who somehow got a Gig on after cook.
I honestly thought he was an amateur because he didn't seem that comfortable on
stage and seem to have really awkward presence.
Fucking useless fucking idiot writing a blog.
Anybody can write a blog.
So this,
this dummy Patosh is,
um,
asking people like to throw out questions so they,
they're throwing out,
you know what,
what should I talk about?
And someone says rape.
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
rape.
That's really funny.
Yeah.
What's funny about that?
The humiliation.
The violence.
You know,
he's like saying ranting on things.
The reason why rape isn't fun,
right?
And so some woman yells out,
actually rape jokes are never funny.
This,
this dump cunt that wrote this blog.
You also this out.
So he says,
wouldn't it be funny if you got raped by like five people right now?
Which is really funny.
You know,
he doesn't really mean that.
What he's trying to do is he's riffing and you're interrupting with some self
righteous horse shit.
Oh,
oh,
you're saying that rape is bad?
Is that what you're saying?
Oh Jesus,
you're at a fucking comedy club.
You asshole.
And this woman writes this,
she writes this whole fucking rambling self serving article about this and now
because of that,
he had to apologize for her because you joked around about rape.
Yup.
That's raper.
Well she's going to get her mind raped on the Internet.
I'm sure.
Cause it's so beyond stupid,
you know?
And she's like,
we were shocked.
We couldn't believe it.
I demand to speak to the manager,
to manage,
speak to the manager is what I said.
We,
we talked about in the icehouse chronicles,
she should be fired from ever going to a comedy club again.
They should take a picture of her.
And every comedy club in the country should agree that this fucking dummy is no
longer allowed to go to comedy clubs.
Put a picture of her.
You're not allowed.
She comes to the door,
blow your rape,
whistle out the agreement.
When you go to those places to just leave that shit behind you,
especially the laugh.
Go there to laugh at the taboos that you think are so sacred that you can't even
touch them.
You know,
things that you're afraid of,
things that your fears,
death,
any of this stuff.
You go there,
you laugh,
you talk about it.
It becomes less serious after that.
I feel more bad for Dane Cook.
Who has this as a fan?
Poor guy.
Couldn't imagine this being one of your fans.
Well apparently Dane Cook,
Burt crash,
it was just joking around and said,
Dane Cook is going to live tweet while my show was on,
you know,
just joking around and Dane got so much fucking hate mail,
like hate tweets right away.
And then Bert crusher started reading them.
It's a lot of fucking people that hate Dang like there's a lot of negativity
attached to being that dude.
And he just got bummed out like it told Bert to please leave them out of this
hole
when we eat about them.
Like yesterday,
whenever we show aired.
Yeah.
If you tweet about,
you know,
Dane is going to just a certain,
for a certain number of people,
that's a free shot.
You're allowed to attack Dane Cook.
It's like men Delia and see that poor fuck he is.
Uh,
he's a fucking doc with concentric circles of various colors.
The red,
white,
he's the duck with a target on him.
I mean,
that's what he built his Karma.
Right.
I haven't heard anything that day,
but need to build a car.
Everyone tweet,
Dane Cook that he has beautiful lips.
Everyone tweaked Dane Cook that he's a big sweetie.
He's a big cute,
cute her son.
It's funny that socks man.
I,
you know,
the Twitter is pretty fucked out.
How,
how that shit can turn on you and just ruin your whole entire day.
Well,
what's fucked up is that,
you know,
anybody can sort of be anonymous and you know,
call your,
I mean there's a lot of pictures of on Twitter of fake accounts where it's like
a hot chick in a bikini and like,
please follow me.
I'm big fan and like you look at a profile and that's her repeating that over
and over again.
They were like a business and they'll,
they'll do that and they'll say,
oh my God,
I just entered into this amazing contest for a free jet ski or whatever the fuck
it is.
Yeah,
sure.
You know,
and they,
you know,
there's,
there's a bunch of people that run,
like there's this one dude that I know that runs thousands of fake Twitter
accounts and when he wants to spam something out,
he spams up the same message on every single Twitter account.
This is why I found it out.
I went to one,
I went to his,
cause I knew that he was scamming people.
So I went to his Twitter account.
I said,
let me look at his tweets.
And then I looked at some of his tweets were responding to people.
So I was like,
well what is he responding to you?
And then I would go to the responding page.
He's responding to himself,
he's writing the same shit and all these different pages.
They all have the same message.
And then I,
I've,
I've followed the chain like a few dozen times to like gave up.
But I just kept finding people and I'd go to the other one.
It was the same thing.
It was the same messages,
all the same tweets.
And I was like,
I wonder how he has this automated,
is he like a program?
Is it spammers?
Use it.
When you say certain things,
like if you say magnet box or whatever you say Toshiba,
they'll,
you'll suddenly get like pesto cheaper prices in town.
Click here for more information.
You know a spam from Twitter,
they'll do it.
Yeah.
There's,
there's robots that just sit there and look for certain keywords and the
timelines and stuff like that.
You hear?
What did you hear about that?
The most,
the biggest Russian spam or from a,
from a few years back is this huge Russian spam or in Russia told him like he
was somehow operating with them some basic rules so they couldn't go after them
legally.
So I kept telling him to stop and he was like,
Oh fuck you guys fucking guys,
whatever.
He was making a shit load of money.
They found him beaten to death with a computer.
Oh my God.
You're like,
you can look that up.
But I was like,
alright motherfucker,
you forget where you're from.
Russia.
Yeah.
Fuck you up and say fuck you and Russia.
You better hide beaten to death with his computer.
They have totally different rules over there for how they deal with Shit.
You can't just get away with stuff like that.
I wonder how they deal with hecklers.
I mean they have like Russia,
the standup comedy,
I don't know.
Probably harshly.
I had a funny story a stripper was telling me about,
she had some Russian stripper friends who she was,
she was stripping with and some girl something,
something wack happen.
Like she got in trouble for giving a hand job on the floor,
the Strip club or something like that.
So she's bawling in the,
in the,
in the room and the Russian stripper goes up to goes,
you want to cry,
you fucking cry alone.
Get out of here.
Like that's just the bucket and that's just the Russian way,
you know?
It's like,
yeah,
you fucking get your shit together and they're hard,
hard bitches.
Yeah.
I give 300 jobs at the same time.
One with foot.
Yeah.
It was still crying and then I send money home to mother Russia.
There's a parts of the world that are cold and dark dude living over there.
That's why I have a few friends that have dated Russian chicks and I always feel
like,
like the,
the getting swindled,
I always feel like something weird is going on.
Like there's something mercenary happening here.
There's so fuck,
you know,
this is a,
I know a guy who's Russian,
who's gay for pay and his boyfriend,
he's straight,
but he's this Russian guy and his boyfriend is this a rich gang guy and this
rich gay guy buys him nice cars,
puts him up in a fat apartment.
I mean really takes care of this guy and it's so that he has sex with them.
I don't know what they do blow jobs or whatever.
I don't know how he rocks the Guy Straight.
And when I found out about him and I'm like,
damn,
that motherfucker is like a Russian whore.
He's like,
he's like a mercenary dude that's willing to suck this old guy's Dick.
You get the feeling that there's still Ferrari,
some kind of harshness of life in Russia.
Like even when you used to see fade or fight,
you know,
just the kind of calmness that he came out there.
And when he's imposing physical violence is about the comments,
like whatever he's been through so much fucking scarier than the giant that he's
about to fight on the other side of the ring that you mean you get that feeling
from,
from everybody.
Not everybody,
but a lot of the people over there like life is so harsh that what,
what you think would be intimidating.
He's just don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
they're not really that concerned with fights.
just to fight.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's still easy.
Did you see his last fight with Pedro Huizar?
I didn't know.
I miss that.
It was brutal.
He,
it's almost too bad that he's retiring now because his standup,
since he started going to Holland,
his standup has really improved a lot.
You've got a lot better.
His He,
he threw some pretty high level shit it Pedro Huizar.
First of all,
you had Pedro staggered just from the speed.
He's really fast for a heavyweight cause he's not a big heavyweight.
He's like two 30 but with a high percentage of body fat.
If you had him lean,
he would probably be about two oh five,
something like that.
And so he moves like a two o five pounds,
really fast.
Two a five pounder.
So he,
his brother
was fast as fuck to good hands.
Two brothers a lot bigger though.
He a,
but he lit Pedro,
his a up man.
He hit him with a leg kick and then he faked the leg kick and threw like a
superman hook and cracked him on the jaw and then just unloaded on him on the
ground.
It's hard to watch man cause page.
Oh his AU is one of those dudes.
It's been around for a long,
yeah.
If you watched a highlight reel of all the towns,
Pedro,
his owes had his life turned out.
It's really hard to watch the Gilbert ival fight the,
you know,
the Josh Barnett fight.
There's a lot of fights over and over again.
We're Pedro,
his husband really hit hard,
really scary knockouts.
I mean,
how many can a man under it's,
that's where it begs the question.
I don't know.
That's,
that's uh,
I think a lot of money in a lot of science is trying to figure that out with
these concussions that they're trying to explore.
If they can figure out how to fix that,
that'll change the price finding world.
Totally.
Yeah.
No,
people don't have to worry about brain damage anymore.
If they can just sort of stick a needle inside your ear and inject some stem
cells and your brain rejuvenates itself.
Yeah.
People would just do extra shots though to get smarter.
They'd be like,
fuck,
Fuck Alpha brain.
I'm going to take a chance on overgrowing my head,
but what if that backfired?
Turned autistic or something a little scary.
Yeah.
I wonder if they're going to be able to eventually figure out a way to
regenerate brain cells because that's a real issue with people with head trauma.
It's just big parts of your brain just are not the same anymore after massive
concussions,
especially if you've had multiple concussions and like football players and
especially fighters in training.
That's the big one.
There's a guy who died recently in an unregulated MMA fight and he got triangled
and a tap from the triangle and was no head trauma at all in the fight.
Went back to his locker room and uh,
and was watching some fights and then someone heard some moaning and they looked
over and he had collapsed and a,
he wound up dying and they brought him to the hospital.
And when they did an autopsy on him that he found,
it was a blunt force trauma from about a week ago.
So it's something that he had sustained.
Pretty sure that's what they had decided.
It wasn't from the,
the fight they were there,
they were pointing to something that happened in training the week before,
like Adrenalin,
dehydration,
little bit of a blood restriction track loader.
Travis Luder fought Marvin Eastman.
Marvin Eastman had getting,
gotten knocked out twice and training.
He got KOD twice and training.
And so when Travis connected with them,
it wasn't even like the hardest punched in the world.
It was weird.
He like caught him on the end of a punch and Marvin just went completely
unconscious.
Like instantly.
It was like,
Whoa,
what's one of those weird ones?
Like what's going on there?
Same thing with Forrest Griffin.
When he fought Anderson Silva,
he had been knocked out twice and training to this.
That's crazy.
Those guys are crazy.
You're getting k out twice and then you're to get k out again.
I mean it's,
but you know,
you sign up for a fight,
you know,
you sign up,
you know this is what you're supposed to be doing and you know,
if you get Keoni and training,
man,
that's just tough shit.
You just,
you just suck it up and you get out there and fight.
That's a fine line between having to believe that you're going to win no matter
what.
And then also being realistic and being like,
yeah,
I should probably bail on this.
Well very few guys,
no one to bail.
That's the hardest part.
The hardest part is knowing when to walk away and everybody wants to walk away
with a win.
You know,
the hardest part is figuring out what the fuck to do with your life next.
Cause when a guy is trying to be a fighter,
he really doesn't have a whole lot of options.
I mean these you're doing one thing,
you know,
and while you're doing that one thing,
that's all you can concentrate on,
it's going to be your whole life period.
And then all of a sudden it's not your life anymore.
Now you got to find something else.
You also got to match that excitement level.
I mean,
how are you going to do that?
This is the most amazing spectacle on the earth.
You know,
you versus another man,
while millions watched and you know,
the triumph and all of those emotions.
I mean you'll never be able to duplicate that.
It's almost impossible unless you become like some crazy downhill skier dudes.
Would he drop you off of a helicopter here?
Yeah,
those guys are on their fucking minds.
It was that.
How long ago did you do your recent,
uh,
this recent trip?
Like how was it months ago or weeks ago or a,
it was like a two way.
I talked,
I talked to Bob about it already.
They don't have it up yet.
So they were asking me.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
I'll just tell you folks,
we're doing a show Wednesday night.
Nice House,
10:00 PM main room.
Big Room tickets will be on the side.
Ari's already have anything Wednesday night.
I don't know.
Um,
definitely me and definitely Brian,
we're going to be in Calgary this week to not you,
Brian doesn't,
I don't go to Canada.
You never take me to Canada.
Do you want to come to Canada?
Fill up next time I go to Vancouver,
you're coming.
Um,
but we're doing the Jack Singer concert hall in Calgary and first show sold out,
but we're doing a second show and that's almost sold out.
But uh,
some tickets are available for the second show.
It's me,
Duncan Trussell and Ari Shaffir and that's this Friday night.
So it is a,
it's about as close to death squad as you can get without Joey Diaz and Brian.
But Joey Diaz is not going to make it to camp.
And that is very cocksucker very strict laws about criminals.
And when you got kidnapping with firearms,
yeah.
They're like,
I know it was a long time ago,
Joey.
He's like,
listen,
I'm a different guy now.
I got 11 cats.
Come on.
They won't let them in.
So I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Canada.
I can't bring Joey Diaz,
but you can always sneak in and hang out with us.
We're,
we're at the ice house all the time.
We've had a bunch of committee,
Canadians and English people and people from all over the world come down and
hang out with the ice house,
which is really cool because the ice house is one of the oldest clubs in the
country.
It started in 1951.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it was not working at 51 or 61.
Uh,
it's been 50 years,
so I don't know.
So that's not even,
I don't know,
whatever it is.
I think it's,
think it started off in the 50s and then the 60s,
it became a comedy club.
I think it was something else before that.
Like some sort of a jazz club or something stupid.
But,
um,
either way,
it's an amazing old club that's run by some really cool people.
They have the nicest wait staff and it's in Pasadena and we do shows there all
the time.
So we'd be there this Wednesday.
And do you ever share their Frye?
I haven't decided yet.
Oh see we're casual shit.
But what we usually do is like last week we had,
oh yes I do.
We had Greg Fitzsimmons,
dom,
I rera Ra should fear.
It's that kind of line up.
It's like all our friends that are in town,
we have them calmed down.
You do have one?
I do have one Friday at 10:00 PM is it in the main room with a small small room?
Small rooms.
Pretty dope too.
The small room was only like 85 seats.
It's like super intimate.
They have two rooms at the ice house,
but it's just like,
there's so much history in there.
Like the other day I went in there with Tommy Chong and uh,
we,
we were,
we were there I think two and Cheech and Chong with chomp.
Tommy t,
yeah,
we Cheech and Chong with Tommy Chong.
I really did.
When you get some,
you say you get high with Tommy Chong,
man,
that is cool as fuck.
Yeah.
And uh,
we went in there and it's like you get feel when you're standing in that room
and it's dark and there's no one on stage and there's no one in the room.
Like you could feel the energy that's been transmitted in that building.
Like that's,
that's a place where decades and decades of standup comedy has gone down.
So we're there a,
this one's a night and you can get tickets@icehousecomedy.com just click on the
link for death squad.
It probably isn't even up yet.
Just call them and tell me one in,
look at it.
They'll sell you a ticket.
They'll figure that shit out.
Use your credit card.
You dirty bitches as in San Diego are amazing.
We had Jim Norton stopped in for one,
didn't even want to go up.
It's like,
well I don't want to go up.
I don't want to ruin these bay.
Tyler like,
wow,
he's so crazy and like go up.
These fucking people would love to see you.
Of course he went on stage.
They went crazy.
American Comedy Code Fort,
that Comedy Club,
if you live in San Diego,
it's amazing.
We're talking about medical and once a month now doing a death squad down there.
Yeah.
The club is the Shit,
the American Comedy Club Company.
It's called the American cotton company and it's literally like the perfect
setup.
You walk in low ceilings,
it's sort of great.
What's,
what's the dude's name from San Jose that uh,
uh,
yeah,
that guy,
that Guy William h Macy there last night.
You did?
They give us,
it's talking right up front.
The front door and I came out.
Oh yeah.
He's there for that show.
Comicon for,
um,
what does it show?
Did you see that she's got a show about a loser family.
I can't remember.
It's hilarious.
Breaking bad was also there though.
And it's staying at the hotel next to the one I was staying at.
The Holt whole cast was there and then on the hotel we stayed at sons of anarchy
was in that whole entire thing.
Yeah.
When we pulled up.
I had to like ask them if I could park because there was like a red carpet thing
going on.
I was like,
is the valet still open?
And they're like,
yeah.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to sneak by the red carpet.
My fucking car park it.
It's weird.
It's like both things were going on at the same time.
It was still actually a hotel and they still had this weird thing going on.
Met Beetle juice too.
Have you ever met that guy?
The guy that really,
really tiny head on Howard Stern.
Stern?
No,
I never met him.
How that was interesting.
I did meet him at the airport once.
I met him at the airport in Atlanta,
I think with Ari.
Oh wait,
no,
I wasn't there with you there.
Yeah,
I'd never said anything.
Then we just saw him just tell him to talk to him.
Yeah.
It's time to talk to him.
He got a picture with you.
I was like,
can I get a picture with you and goes,
you do what you gotta do?
And I'm like,
all right,
cool.
San Diego's a pretty fucking bad ass live there except for the the military
thing.
Military Weed and uh,
I don't know the hot blonde thing.
It's tons of blondes down there for summaries that bad.
What the fuck is no,
no,
no.
I mean I think,
but I didn't notice.
It's really weird that there's a lot of blond people I was looking around and
it's like every single person has blonde hair.
It's to counteract Mexico.
It's like
Terry there gravitate towards that area.
They don't even know why it's a gene pool bouncing out situation.
But yeah,
San Diego is a fucking awesome town,
man.
I love it there.
It's one of my favorite places to go,
but it really is bizarre that they have,
like La Jolla has these 30 40 $50 million houses,
giant estates overlooking the water.
20 minutes from Tijuana,
20 minute drive to deal.
We had a bunch of tea.
You want of people came to the show,
you know,
I didn't know it was that easy to just drive over.
I made the drive with a few times.
But you,
if you live in Tiawana,
you could drive over to America and just see a show.
Absolutely.
What's really the line?
The line going across the border is fucking serious.
That would keep you from just staying,
I guess they don't.
If you're a legal citizen on the,
eventually we don't have to live,
but you don't have to have a visa or anything.
I come over here.
You just just hop over.
We,
we met a lot of people from team won.
It was like five or six people at the show.
They came from Tijuana.
There were fans of the podcast.
It was weird.
I was like,
damn,
you look skinny.
Give here.
Don't miss back.
I like it down there.
I wish we could live down there.
It would be wrong.
Yeah.
No,
no.
San Diego bold choice.
I like that.
Like car and auto island.
Just go on that island.
There was just people playing,
playing softball at this park and you're just on this island.
It's just,
well that Allison,
beautiful islands,
one of the most expensive pieces of real estate in the country.
I could tell.
Yeah.
That island has some insane houses on it.
That a,
that's where Donald Rumsfeld lives.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's fucking,
you could smell fire and brimstone is to drive over the bridge.
A lot of rich industrialists and all sorts of fancy pants folks live on that
island.
Yeah,
I don't,
I dunno.
Uh,
that's a,
that's a real rich spot.
San Diego's got a lot of rich areas like La Hoya.
The Hoya is gorgeous.
That's where the comedy store is.
That's an amazing town.
Beautiful Man.
When we used to stay there,
I'd be like,
I would figuring out,
can I live here whenever we would do like comedy down there,
but can I live here?
It's only two hours away.
Why can I live here?
I could just send if you're lucky.
Two hours.
Yeah.
Four and a half for me.
It took me four and a half to get to the show.
No doubt.
What should we talk about a little on it stuff before we wrap this up here?
Yeah.
So latest,
uh,
latest news in the audit world,
we got,
uh,
the new Alpha brain formula,
which is a,
just a slight tweak on the old Alpha brain formula.
Basically,
the acetylcholine mechanism remains exactly the same.
You have the WHO Persia Serrata as the Acetylcholine esterase inhibitor and you
have Alpha GPC is the raw source of Coleen to raise your acetylcholine levels.
And then,
uh,
for the dopamine mechanism we're using El tyrasine,
which is the basic source amino acid for El Dopa.
Uh,
instead of Mucuna periods,
I'm much more research behind El tyrasine and uh,
it's just seems to be a preferred ingredient for that.
And instead of the,
um,
supplemental Gaba,
we switched that out with [inaudible],
which is actually why when you drink green tea you don't get that kind of
hyperactive feeling that you do from coffee necessarily because green tea
contains natural healthy Janine,
which is related to the Gabba mechanism and kind of keeps you from getting too
hyper and a that's again going to temper that kind of vary a little bit manic
effect of the mental speed and that kind of focus that you get from these,
the a acetylcholine.
Um,
and then we added a phosphatidyl Serin,
which is a great ingredient.
Got a couple of cool studies with phosphatidyl serin.
One was,
which was,
um,
measuring the accuracy of people off of a golf tee,
driving towards a whole 135 yards away and found statistically significant
improvement in a double blind study for the people taking phosphatidyl serin as
far as hitting the ball straighter and what they,
what they found is that it just helps reduce mental fatigue.
It's a natural nutrient that's found in brain cell membranes.
I'm when to use it to rape down my rare and pool tonight.
Yes,
you should Max,
by the way,
Max separately,
one of the best pool player is a great instructor is just raving about Alpha
brain.
Yeah,
you sent me a tad.
Loves it as well.
He loves phosphatidyl Serin as well.
He's been using that for a long time,
so,
uh,
he's,
he's super pumped about it so,
well it's,
it's,
it's fascinating to me that this is a new frontier for a lot of folks.
You know,
a lot of people aren't really aware that there are a bunch of different
nutrients that have shown that they have a positive effect on your brain
function.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
And then,
uh,
I guess everything else remains the same.
The AC 11 are proprietary antioxidant that comes from the rain forest Derbe
cat's claw,
um,
that they concentrate some of the alkaloids and really help you kind of clear
away some of your mental fog.
And then,
uh,
the BACOPA and the B six to help,
help round out the formula.
But I'm getting great feedback on the,
on the new form.
And again,
just a slight tweak for any of those who've been fans of the old alpha brain.
But,
uh,
definitely,
just a little bit better on all fronts.
And then we have the uh,
the Strawn bone and joint formula,
which we came out with,
which is new and that's focused around the,
the mineral strontium and a New England Journal of Medicine Study from 2004
showed that the people taking strontium ranelate I had a 41% decrease fracture
risk as far as developing the bone density.
And that's because strontium is one of the key minerals along with calcium
that's found in the bones.
And a lot of our processed foods have eliminated the natural strontium content.
So it's,
you know,
one of the theories why so many people are experiencing osteoporosis is because
the natural strontium that generally comes from our foods,
we're not getting them anymore.
And then find him and mark or deficiencies or calcium is,
you know,
yeah,
general mineral deficiencies.
And so we bought a bunch of other trace minerals in there.
Put some pretty traditional things for your joints,
MSM,
glucosamine,
hyaluronic acid,
and just make a kind of balance formula with the ingredient strontium,
which is best.
And a lot of these studies do have it in conjunction with calcium.
So we recommend taking,
but you're not supposed to take them at the same time cause I'll actually
compete for absorption because there's such a similar molecule.
So you take the strong bone or your strontium supplement in the morning per se,
and then take a calcium supplement at night.
So great formula for,
you know,
people who are in kind of active sports or if you're getting up there in age or
just want a better,
a better general bone and joint strength and flexibility.
And then,
uh,
some exciting new stuff coming out.
We got our hemp forest product,
which is fucking delicious,
like really good.
Just,
it's very simple.
The best tasting protein powder I've ever had.
And it's the best for you.
Yeah.
The crazy thing is about how less I fart on that.
So yeah,
totally.
It's incredible.
I do it with coconut water.
Now see two o has this new version that uh,
Brian scared of you just taste like Paul goobers tastes like coconut loans will
be,
I know,
probably like a coconut.
I just shot it little in your mouth,
but it's um,
the coconut with pulp in it.
So he told us not a sponsor,
but there are friends.
So,
uh,
we,
them and alien ware,
uh,
we talk about them just because they're cool and they hook us up.
Alienware her December,
some cool computers and [inaudible] keeps US hydrated.
But I make,
I make shakes with,
um,
the,
uh,
hemp force and CTO and it's fucking delicious and no gas.
Not that I would make.
I would make these fucking muscle milkshakes,
which tastes so good,
but would burn holes in the seat of my car while I was farting on the way they
judge is like Jesus a lot.
That's fun now and then,
Oh,
it's got times.
Why don't you want to Fart?
Fighting's fine.
There's a lot of issues with whey protein digestion.
I mean if you,
if you aren't careful,
it can create intestinal toxemia,
which is like a sludge that builds up in your intestines and actually prevents
the absorption of nutrients beyond that.
But it is a,
it is a very balanced kind of protein.
It's just really tough for the human body to kind of metabolize it.
Whereas hemp on the other hand,
hemp hearts,
two thirds of that is made up of a compound called [inaudible],
which is already very commonly found,
the human body.
So there's virtually no allergy or digestion issues.
Plus he got all the Omega Omega threes and sixes fatty acids in there.
The Gla,
um,
just a super protein for you.
And all we did was add some cocoa,
which is again,
another one of the original superfoods,
you know,
got a bunch of good trace minerals,
chromium and,
and a variety of other things and uh,
and Maka as well.
Long traditional use of Maka,
being able to boost libido and also could chain a bunch of nutrients that
support the endocrine system and a little bit of Stevia.
And uh,
he's got a fucking delicious drink that'll refuel yourself.
Good.
How launch were you?
Super Healthy.
Easy to digest,
like everything about it.
I love,
it's my new favorite all time protein powder and no gas brother.
Let's that.
That Brian and the beauty of Stevie.
I love Stevie.
Yeah.
Stevie was interesting stuff.
If you could have too much of that stuff though.
If you try to put like a spoonful of and you're coughing,
it's almost on.
It's so strong.
The End Stevia though.
Two favorites.
Well,
Gavi is not necessarily good for you and your job,
it not really.
Yeah.
I always thought it was.
It sounds like herbal and shit like,
um,
have a little of Gavi and my,
it's basically like simple shirt that scores are up.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fucked up.
It tastes good.
You know?
Look again,
moderation,
but Stevia,
way better for your body.
Way Better.
He just a little jazz of Stevia,
but the Stevia in a hemp force.
It's a,
it's a delicious combination.
The combination of the marker,
the cocoa,
the raw cocoa and the hemp fiber all together.
Oh,
it's good.
It's good.
It's my favorite.
Yeah,
I fucked that shit up,
man.
You gave me a tub of that stuff.
I killed that in two days.
I was fucking drink it at all the time.
I had two in a row because they were so good.
But muscle milk's pretty God damn good too.
But for me the fart drop off is it's really worth it.
But I feel like I can work out quicker to like go would I like whey protein.
But um,
a lot of times when I would take it I would feel like a little slow for like an
hour and a half cause he's got all that blood in that trying to deal with that
shit.
Yeah,
it was just an absorb easily.
It's not as,
not nearly as easily absorb as plant braced a protein,
hemp protein if you're looking for another time,
protein to the,
probably the second best I think is a combination of rice and pea protein
together.
They're very complimentary protein.
Those are pretty good.
They don't have the extra nutrients that hamp does or the pedestrian that's part
of the human body.
But that's a pretty good one.
Soy has a lot of issues too.
Plus you don't get stone or credit,
get straight stolen or credit from eating ham protein.
We show bitches your muscles.
The shit came from him,
came from the hamp and they had to bring it in from Canada because we're too
stupid to grow messes like this Keenan here in America to legal.
How stupid in way.
That's one of the really the most hurtful things about this retarded government.
No Ham.
And by the way,
Henry Ford made the first car at a hamp.
You know we talked about this in the podcast is a video you can get online.
It's pretty dope.
Have you ever seen it,
Brian?
Yeah,
he hits it with a hammer so it a few times it hits the fucking fenders with a
hammer and the the,
this fiberglass that he's made out of hemp is so strong.
The hammer's just bouncing off of it.
Frank,
I wanted to get a corvette.
Let me just throw this out there.
See if anybody knows how this can be done.
I wanted to get a corvette and then get the body panels made out of hemp.
How hard would that be to do?
Would that be really hard to do?
Somebody telling me if it's dingy,
ask that last week.
Yeah I did,
but no one,
no one responded.
They probably got too high.
Anybody who knows how to Doug,
I have the resources that you seek.
So
if they really did know how to do it,
they forgot to get back.
But I just want to know is there,
someone responded me on Twitter if you know,
is there a way to do that?
Because if there is a way to do that,
that would be bad ass.
I like that.
Must think better than I liked that corvette.
Yeah.
I don't think you should get a red car.
Shut up son.
I'm,
I'm in love with this new Mustang.
This is a new Mustang Shelby that's coming out.
It's got,
I think it's,
it's,
I think I said it wrong,
I think.
Oh yeah.
It's 650 horsepower.
Not 640.
It's six 5,650 horsepower in a Mustang.
I mean it's hilarious.
Three miles per gallon.
No,
it actually doesn't even have a gas guzzler tax because it's,
um,
it's not naturally aspirated as a supercharger on it.
So it's a big Ass v eight,
but it's really efficient.
And then on top of that,
it's connected to a radical fucking supercharger that is,
gives you this mad wine over the roar of the Va.
But I'm in love with this car,
man.
This might be my next shit I guess.
Well,
I wanted to,
I look,
I like,
I have a Mustang.
I have a Shelby gt 500 convertible.
I like,
but I'm not really that far.
I'm not really that cool.
Would convertibles just too many variables.
I've seen too many cars flip over on the highway and shit.
I'm like,
that doesn't seem like a smart thing because you can have a metal roof.
You know,
you probably should have a metal roof.
But um,
but I,
I love the idea of getting an American car that's a fun car.
And if there's anything that America does right,
it's making muscle cars.
It's so last shit we do right when it comes to manufacturing.
And I just love the fact that these guys were really going for it,
that they really have made a 650 fucking horsepower Mustang.
I mean,
I almost feel like I'm obligated to buy something like this because they're,
they're so silly that they made it.
That's how I felt like about a,
the corvette zr one.
I felt the same way about that.
Dude.
It's so silly that they made such a crazy car.
I feel like obligated because if I was a kid and I was like,
man,
if I,
you know,
if I saw something like that about it,
man,
if I had enough money,
I'd buy one of those,
you know?
Yeah.
That's what you should do.
You should buy one of those if you have enough money.
I got one.
I got the challenge.
I love it.
Yeah.
Challenges a dope car.
It's again,
it's American muscle car.
They figured out how to make it right.
They're fun to draw.
They sound good.
I'm not alone.
These sound like they're alive.
They have some fucking passion to them.
Right,
Brian [inaudible] that's the last thing we do well when we do a lot of shit.
Well,
we have the best music.
We have the best comedy socket.
If you disagree,
suck it.
Suck it.
Yeah.
England has some good music in England,
has some good
comedy,
but that's about it.
The rest of the world can suck my dad,
you know,
I mean Japanese make a few pretty bad ass cars.
Your comedy is ridiculous.
Stop.
I know he invented martial arts,
but comedy's got to go out the window.
Anything to say Brian,
before we wrap this up?
Brian did something yesterday.
Not good for his head and right now I think when I smoked weed it just kicked it
back in probably.
Yeah.
I'm pretty pretty good right now.
What's Kamari settle the fuck around?
Is that the,
is that how you get girls?
Talk to him.
Wake up.
Come here girl.
Come here.
I felt it felt vulnerable.
Um,
anything more?
No,
that's it.
I've been a super active on my blog,
so if anybody wants to keep up with me,
warrior poet.us.
You have a podcast,
a podcast.
Just had a podcast with Mitch Schultes,
a Dmt,
the spirit molecule.
It's fucking really cool conversation.
I keep them to about an hour,
but I,
that was really cool.
So check it out.
You can see the links from a warrior poet.
Dot Us.
Nice.
Beautiful.
All right.
And we got several podcasts this week.
Tomorrow we have Bobo from finding big foot.
I am fucking very excited.
I have but find that motherfucker already.
Come on Paul.
If anybody's gonna find it,
finding bigfoot,
foot's going to find it.
Um,
this,
uh,
James Bobo Fay and he's squasher on Twitter if you want to file and he's,
he's tomorrow and then I'm fucking site cause I've been addicted to big foot
since I was a little kid.
I can't tell you many documentaries I've watched and books I've read have been
fascinating.
This guy has seen a Sasquatch,
allegedly.
Did you say,
did you see the South Park about big foot?
Yeah,
no,
I should really watch south park about everything.
Uh,
so that's uh,
that's Tuesday.
Wednesday we have Justin Helpern on the podcast.
He's the guy who wrote shit.
My Dad says he wrote the movie and he's got a book called,
I suck at girls.
It's his newest book and a very funny guy,
so he'll be joining us.
Then next week we got honey,
honey,
immortal tech,
Robb Wolf,
and Maynard keen.
My God,
that's week four,
week four days of chaos.
That's the next week.
The week after that we got Tom Roads.
We've got a lot of shit happening.
You dirty bitches,
Jack Singer,
concert hall this Friday night.
[inaudible] meet Duncan Trussell calm.
Get your freak on Calgary.
There's still tickets available for the 10:00 PM show.
Thank you to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t and if you want to buy some supplements,
use the code name Rogan and save yourself 10% off.
We cannot give you this sort of a discount on the battle ropes and the kettle
bells is because they're as cheap as we can possibly sell them.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and the best fucking quality you're going to get.
These cattle bells are made out of solid motherfucking iron and long after
you're dead,
archeologists will find these bitches the bottom of the ocean and try to figure
out what the fuck they are and they'll go,
oh,
this is what Mike used to get swole as fuck.
Go check them out.
Go get 'em,
go get yourself on a fucking workout program.
We have all sorts of different,
you can buy them in packages,
all sorts of different packages for beginners and for people who are a bit more
experienced.
There's a hundred different fucking more videos on youtube of different
kettlebell techniques and there's a lot of DVDs and stuff that's available as
well.
We're eventually going to make our own DVD.
We're going to get on that.
We'll probably talk about that as soon as we shut off this fucking podcast.
Okay,
so we've got to get to it.
All right.
We love you guys.
We will see you tomorrow.
Thank you everybody for all the positive energy and all the positive tweets and
all the cool mother fuckers that come out to these comedy shows and it's
overwhelming you for sure.
We have tapped into some sort of a vein of the coolest people on Earth.
And I,
you know,
we hear from all you people that we are contributing to your happiness and we
are contributing to your positive energy and make no mistake about it.
We feel very obligated,
very connected,
and,
and we,
we were all a part of this thing.
We're all part of this thing together.
We're just the antenna and whatever the radio,
the thing that keeps it moving.
I ran out of cliches.
I'll see you fucking freaks tomorrow.
Keep it in your pants unless you're going to use it.
[inaudible].